[Music]
this is so weird
how did i why are you here i don't know
exactly
how did i convince you to do this i'm
actually i like on your instagram like
every day and i watch like your stories
with benton
every day so it is kind of weird for me
because it's sort of like
it's like watching the kardashians and
i'm like here in the kardashians home
i'm rob pretty exciting i see the whole
like it's like you're in our show and i
feel like i'm in your show like it's
just this weird two worlds colliding all
of a sudden
i have been thinking about you coming on
i was thinking about you a lot last
night not in a creepy way and um
and i was like she just seemed so
you just seemed like such an angel to me
and i worried
i was like am i gonna be good at
interviewing her because
i don't sense any ostensible brokenness
from you
i don't sense any dysfunction what if
you just start crying
um
like there's i don't feel like
dysfunction from you
i don't feel uh uh anything
um uh sort of like negative
and that's what i tend to be able to
like latch on to and then we started
texting
and you're really funny and i was like
oh maybe she does have some damage
because you were so funny over text it's
funny that you were worrying about this
because i was worrying about talking to
you because i'm not like exciting
and you seem like very exciting to me so
really like super exciting
like you seem like a blast like you're
like really fun to hang out with always
doing like wild fun things
just because i uh i dress like brad pitt
in natural born killers
and i've dyed my hair pink this isn't
exciting miranda this is called
desperate
there's a difference to me i want to do
some like blue um
maybe let's do it i totally would do it
i was thinking about you also because i
was like
okay i was like here's what i'm gonna do
in this interview she's younger you're
seven i was like i'm gonna help her with
all of her problems and
that would be great and i was like i'm
gonna help her like not make all the
mistakes i made and then i meet you and
i'm like i feel like i can learn so much
from her
i could use a lot of help especially
like in the dating tell me is it weird
to date
being so famous um it's weird to date
no matter period yeah yeah it's just
like horrible it's like really
hard out here really so do guys and you
are
probably this is the most boomer thing
i'll ever say like all digital right
like um i just joined like a dating app
for the first time like three months ago
maybe four months ago okay and it's been
what's your tagline
very hard what's your um i don't have
anything i didn't put it
i just left it completely blank slate
that's what it should be in my 20s
my tinder bio would just have been blank
slate completely blank you can project
anything onto me i will become whatever
you need me to be
so you didn't even put a thing i mean my
name's there in my age
what we'll write it for you let us write
it yeah i could use something that's how
pretty you are just like i think my face
speaks for itself
no i don't really need a tagline
definitely you inter you out
but i met this i met a guy okay like a
few weeks in and i thought like wow i
should have done this like a million
years ago like
i met like i'm gonna marry this guy like
that's literally what i thought
how okay you meet him and when did you
think i'm gonna marry this guy like
the fourth time i went out with him yeah
it was really insane you waited
he really waited long did i held out and
um
it turned out he was married okay so
okay you you knew he was the marrying
type
you were right about something i could
sense that this guy's not afraid of
commitment i can feel that from him oh
yeah so much so that he is
married yeah so he was on a dating app
cheating well technically it's a little
confusing so he
had a kid and he was married at one
point and
he um hadn't signed the divorce papers
but didn't say that
and then like later on he was like um
yeah like this isn't going that great
anyway and by the way i didn't sign the
divorce papers yet
and i was just like okay
so that was my first dating app
experience so okay
it wasn't great let me ask you you said
sparks fly sparks fly like electricity
so he's like i'm not you see when i was
your age i would have turned that into a
positive
i would have been like he didn't sign
the papers he didn't print it out he's
green
good for the environment he saved a tree
by not signing those papers
um and so how old was he 22. oh well
okay well yeah what do we do what are we
okay okay
sorry i'm not gonna okay i'm not gonna
overthink this too much
i was gonna really get granular and
break that down
although i do think younger guys
are better i've started dating younger
guys
um uh my version of younger guys is
probably still old and creepy
for you but i just um dated a guy who's
30 and
they i'm finding that younger guys
respect women a little bit more i don't
know if it's because they grew up with
beyonce or something but
there's a lot of um uh reverence or
something
or maybe it's fear and i'm just turning
it into reference like are guys
respectful to you um maybe i think
you're right
but i'm thinking maybe it's because
there's a paper trail of everything now
with texting you have to be true you
have to be like nicer over like text and
stuff
yeah the 22 year old played a lot of
video games i spent a lot of time
watching him play video games
planning our marriage while he played um
world of warcraft
okay we do okay we do okay so what is
this
why do you think that that is something
you
that would ever be deserving of you
i don't know it was bad but then um i'm
back on there now
okay back out there back out there take
two head in the game
i don't i still don't have a bio or
anything going on we're gonna by the end
of the
um podcast we're gonna have her bio yeah
for her dating app we'll write it i
would appreciate it yeah
i could definitely use some help and so
what attracted you to this person in the
first place
um he was very cute said hello to me
okay that was it
the bars so can i tell you something i
was thinking about this the other day i
was talking to a friend of mine and i
was like it is amazing
how low our bars are and we constantly
have to
re-up them re-think about them like
we give people points for things
when it's just like you don't deserve
points for doing the bare minimum
yeah i was talking to a friend of mine
and and she was like and he called
instead of texted and i was like no no
you don't get points for that you don't
get points for that that's pretty great
you really don't get points
yeah no you do not get points for
calling calls anymore especially not a
pandemic
um and just little things like that
where i find myself just like really
being like why did i give out points for
just
basic respect that's true i've given out
points for very small things
so let me ask you um what would you say
in your
history of dating would be the most
common reason why relationship ended
besides you emasculating them because
you're so successful what's the reason
you think it is
either because the guy wanted to be in a
boy band or was already in a boy band
oh my god if i spit on this shirt
i just freaking steam the shirt for you
if i spit coffee on it because you're
funny i'm gonna be so pissed
that is hilarious literally why yeah no
you know my rule no musicians or
magicians
boy bands are bad though because it's
like they're like practicing like dance
moves a lot
and then like and then like if you're
over 20 years old and you're still like
you're not going to get in one most
likely because
like and if you're over 21 and still
calling yourself a boy
that is truly the reddest flag of all
the red flags
you're not going to get anyone most
likely you go to tick tock
and so what is the longest relationship
you've been in um
five years wow oh long what do you
really know
but it started when i was like 15. so
does that count
yeah i think it counts i think it counts
and so what do you want in
in somebody you seem like you get your
emotional needs met
in a healthy way you're very surprised
of warcraft
you're very self-possessed you're like
have kind of everything you need and
like what what can a man do for you um
what could you possibly
need i just like people that are funny
that's like honestly the number one
thing
is if somebody is funny okay i like love
funny people and that doesn't mean
thinks they're funny we decide if you're
funny you don't decide if you're funny a
lot of you
think you're funny or you think you're
funnier than you are because you've had
a lot of girls
laugh at your jokes that aren't funny
and enabled you
uh but truly funny and funny doesn't
mean oh
funny also doesn't mean uh uh
uh why don't you give cher uh cher wants
her shirt back
that was mean why'd you say that it was
a joke if you have to say
it's a joke after you've insulted us
that doesn't mean you're funny
why did you look at me when you i don't
know because i was trying to think of a
share
a fresher reference than cher so i just
looked your direction like share or like
i love share it's a good that's a good
reference
and so what's your ideal way a guy
is going to court you so you're going to
match on a dating app
then what he's going to message you
first um we're going to hang out
i don't well now you can't really go to
like a restaurant or anything but that's
what i was going to but i want to get
granular he's going to text you first
that'd be nice right you're not texting
first you're like hoping
are you texting first no i'm not okay
good you're not initiating good
no i've never initiated i'm too scared
okay good are you scared of things
yes i'm a very like scared type i would
never like text somebody first
even like first of all good but why the
fear i don't know i just feel like or
like
i don't know like when you're first
getting to know somebody like i always
wait like at least three weeks before i
text the person first
is that bad like i'll just let them like
hopefully they'll say something to me
and if not i'll just like wait it out no
that's good
i think that's actually really smart
because i've spent so much of my life
running point on a relationship to the
and doing all the work
and then when you stop you realize
there's really no relationship i was
doing
their side and my side and i was just
micromanaging it and kind of
ordaining it to happen and you have to
just do nothing
to see how they're going to show up it
is kind of bad though because it's like
game playing already at the start you're
not game playing though you're i think i
think game playing
is about your motives you're not trying
to manipulate them it doesn't seem like
you're just like hoping they're
interested in seeing if like they'll
message you
but it seems kind of nice sometimes to
reach out maybe it'd be better i don't
know
interesting i am fascinated by you
she doesn't you have just the kindest
heart and the kind of sweetest energy i
guess
why is there such a stereotype that
people that weren't famous when they
were young are like a mess
does that annoy you seems like i know it
seems like people always think that
about like people that
acted when they were young but i started
acting in a really weird way like when i
was like three
i am like an agent came up to my mom and
then i started going on auditions
and i didn't like it like i did not like
auditioning or like anything
it's healthy yeah you're like that's it
that's a healthy reaction
and then i like quit like i didn't do it
for a while and then
my mom like tried to get me to do it
again and then i kind of i started to
like it like when i was like seven or
eight years old but i still have always
been like a basket case
like nervous wreck over like auditioning
and i think that it's because like ever
since i was like really little it's
always like freaked me out like
it should freak you out it's i you there
is a war on fear
you guys know me and my hot takes you
know i am pro fear and i am pro-anxiety
i mean auditioning i don't think people
understand whenever someone slams actors
or actresses it makes me so mad because
i have so much respect for any actor or
actress because what you don't realize
is that for every one job they get
300 times they went into a room full of
like nine adults
at a table and you go in and it's it's
like being on like
nine first dates at once and you have to
perform
and you're reading stuff they wrote that
you have to match what they thought of
in their head like i mean it is
such a nightmare that's why i have to
take beta blockers that actually sounds
really good
it works something it works whitney
cummings gets miranda cosgrove booked on
drugs
i cannot wait to see that headline but
really it makes you feel like
so beta blockers are all they do is take
away adrenaline
so i don't do like people do um like
xanax and and benzodiazepines i can't do
those they make you tired
this just takes away adrenaline so the
nervousness you know and then when you
go into a meeting or something and then
you're nervous and then you say
something dumb and then you're beating
yourself up because you just said
something dumb then you start sweating
and then you're like
trying to hide your armpits because
you're sweating and it just turns into
this like whack-a-mole of like a shit
show fucking rat fuck nightmare
so it basically just stops adrenaline so
you can go and you might still fuck up
and have a bad meeting but at least it's
not because you're nervous
or that your adrenaline's got the best
of you when i was little i used to like
i'd walk by like the room and i'd try to
see like how many people were inside and
if there were more than like five people
i'd be like i don't want to go like i'm
out i don't want to go in like i had it
down to like a very
weird science i know your boundaries
i did i remember one of my not one of my
first auditions but
when i first started like getting like
big callbacks and like testing for stuff
you know the way that you make tv shows
is you first go in and a casting
director sees you the first person and
then if you get past the casting
director you get to meet the producers
and then if you meet get past the
producers
you get to meet the network and all this
is changing now you just have to make a
tick tock video and a tiny crop top and
you're
famous but this is back in the day uh
and then sometimes you would go in and
the actor would be there and you'd have
to work with the actor that you were
opposite there's like all these stages
it's like scientology
you would like go you know the stages of
thetan or whatever
and i remember sometimes you go in and
you wouldn't know who would be in the
room
i remember i remember one time i had
worked on this audition for so long i
was ready i go in to meet the producers
right and they're like it's a producer
session i'm like great i walk in
there's like 10 people and like will
smith
i literally watched that would have
really thrown me i walked and i went
oh come on i literally was just like
fuck you guys
no warning at all about will smith being
in the room
i probably could remember no warning
truly i don't have to do the lines with
will smith
no he was just a producer and he was
just like in there that day and i was
just like fuck
you guys like i literally just said that
i mean i was like 26 i had no idea what
i was doing and they started laughing
and i bombed the audition but it's just
like sometimes you just have some random
curveball like that
i feel like people like famous people if
they're in auditioning rooms should like
hide themselves like they should be
behind like uh
some kind of a sheet or something yeah
like a guy
yeah like they don't want to ruin it for
like just like it's a changing screen
you know what's really weird the person
that i melted down in front of
the most in an audition randomly you
probably won't even know who this is
henry rollins i went to audition for uh
when i first started in
la i was doing um commercial auditions
and i
i've never booked a commercial uh
because i
sound sorry because i
because i sound sarcastic when i'm
trying to be genuine so i'd be like buy
whisk it really cleans your dishes like
i like it never
it always sounded like i was making fun
of the product and they're like can you
actually like
pretend like you like the product i'm
like no i do like the product and it
just like
never worked and i don't even know where
i'm going with this
do you know you had a breakdown in front
of someone
oh henry rollins okay so i
did some hosting which is when you go in
and you're just like hi i'm so-and-so
like i
i was almost an mtv vj or whatever and i
was like testing for those so they
started sending me on like which i now
just fully look like an mtv vj
20 years after the audition 20 years
after the audition i nailed the look
and uh so i go in for a hosting thing
and it's like some show about music or
something on vh1 i don't know i was like
was that do you even know what vh1 is
yeah i know what fiance is i know it
well
she's like i'm triggered um and i went
in and henry rollins was there
and i i'm from dc he's from dc i
actually couldn't even tell you a henry
rollins song
like i guess i just there's somewhere in
my hippocampus henry rollins just like
had some kind of power of me i started
like shaking and freaking out and i
didn't have the wherewithal to go like
you know you guys can i go like take a
walk and like
have a handful of almonds maybe eat a
couple nuts hydrate and come back like i
couldn't i just completely humiliated
myself
i feel like there's a tape of that
somewhere anyone that worked
at vh1 between 2005
and 2007. if there's an audition tape of
me
please leak it anyone who's a big fan of
mine from then who's still listening
you could just send in my really killer
tape i always hope that they burned my
tapes when i leave
like i went on this one audition like a
year or so ago and um i was supposed to
cry
like in the in the scene i can't cry
like i literally
i can cry a lot in real life but like
when i'm trying to act like there's just
no way you're like i've been crying all
morning
so it's just like i'm not getting a lot
of tears because i just like
i cry every morning when i wake up if
you catch me anytime after 6 p.m
and before 10 a.m i'm crying so just
come over that at that moment
and i'll bring a video of you crying
like see this is
i only can't cry because i'm dehydrated
from crying so much it was so awkward
though because they were like
that was good like good job but like if
you cry like
you could have the part like they
actually said that inside like in the
audition
and i was like okay i was like could i
can i have a moment like to really like
get into this and they were like yeah
like sure so i left and i went to the
bathroom and i had a tear stick
like you know yeah yeah oh my god it's
like burning basically may i
can i explain this really quick sure so
all of those genius
actors that you love have something
called a tear stick
it's a it's menthol it's like gas
basically it's menthol
it's chapstick that's menthol and they
put it under there
burns the hell out of nails and they
bend down or when they go to rub their
eyes when they're crying in a scene they
put menthol in their eyes and that makes
them cry a lot
and you think they're geniuses yes
sucker
but i went in the bathroom and i got it
out and i hadn't used it and like i
hadn't had to cry in an audition in like
six years
so when i took it out it um it had dried
out
oh shit so i like got it and i was like
trying to put it under my eyes i was
putting like
a ton of it under my eyes and like not
it just didn't work at all
nothing and then i was just like wow
stick around your eye
chapstick they probably were like what
the hell is going on
but um but anyway i went back in and i
didn't cry and then i was just like
thank you so much
thank you for your time and then i went
to the car and i cried
so that's my like bad auditioning story
from
kind of reason a year ago and then
another time i had to sing time after
time
on an audition that was like horrible i
asked if i could do it again and i could
just feel like the whole room like
no please don't do it again why
because it was terrible like when i sang
the song it was genuinely awful
it like came out like a weird whisper
because i was like nervous
and when i get nervous i can't like sing
at all like not even a little bit
so i think is your um chest constricts
or something i don't know why i'm not
sure like
the science behind it but it was bad and
it basically came out like a weird
whisper and then
i thought like it'd get better like why
is she serenading us what's happening
they all looked really it was really bad
like you can sing that what what's that
what is that
what is that why do you do that alone
like in the shower but let me ask you
something but you're a public
you're a pop star what are you
what is this is this a thing that you
have to do to make people like you
no it's not because they get so jealous
of you or do you believe this
i sing terribly has this business
destroyed your self-worth no when i'm
around like
small groups of people i can't sing it's
like it's a real thing
there's no way but do you have to uh
self-deprecate like is that how you got
through life
maybe maybe that's because you don't you
think people were probably jealous of
you at school
um i don't know actually i mean i went i
only went to regular school until like
fifth grade and i started doing
homeschooling
so and that's why you're so normal you
don't have a theory that schooling made
me normal can i tell you something uh
hot take hot take you know i'm known for
my hot tank
my hot take is that homeschooled people
school fucks you up dude why is
everyone's like school's so healthy for
people to go
i mean get bullied by a bunch of like
kids on accutane
that are going crazy i mean school
my last name is coming so school was
traumatizing for me but uh
i know a lot of home school kids that
are really well adjusted
and lovely and ch and you know what
hot tape cat dennings and um also that
um child stars i have this theory that
like child stars are the sanest people i
know
the craziest people i know we're not
famous as children
i just feel like we've taken like a
couple of the ones that went crazy and
just really amplified it
there's a war on child stars and i am
going to fight i'm going to help them
okay we need to get back to um your
dating
because i'm gonna fix this i'm gonna
solve this
um he doesn't text okay you're not gonna
text him for three weeks
he's gonna text you we never speak we
don't speak
for about a year but by the way that's
like my dream
um but do you get scared like do you get
scared
of just strangers who are these people
oh you mean because you're just like
meeting up with these friends yeah
i mean i'm coming with you on your dates
from now on i mean who are these people
okay this is really i'm really stressed
out for you thanks
i'm really stressed out too about it
i've been trying to figure it out for a
long time do you let people set you up
um yeah i totally would but um i had a
friend that would set me up on like
anybody she went out with once that went
really badly she'd like set me up with
that person
what is that i do that all the time
where i'll
like a guy it won't go well nugget but
you should date my friend like you'd be
perfect
for her i always did that and i'm always
like if they weren't like good with you
like and she'd be like i don't know like
maybe you'll like you're different than
me like maybe you'll like him but it'd
always be like the same
problem usually right right right and
what's the most annoying thing that
you're finding in
guys uh dating online um most annoying
besides posing with tigers in your
photos you fucking tools
i know that's the worst but um i don't
know probably
i noticed that like a lot of guys will
like ask you out and you'll go on like
one
date and then they think that's like it
like they took you on one date so like
then now it's called coffee from there i
want to like sit at their house and like
not really do anything or come up with
any plans
so that's like a major thing that always
happens like one date one good one
and then they like did it that is so
true holy shit
one date and then they're like nailed it
like we went and got lemongrass chicken
now we're gonna just
hang in each other's houses for three
months yeah it's so bad
like and boxes it kind of
well yeah the pandemic has made it a
little bit murky people but it's like
still no you can still go on to hike
yeah you can still hike you can still
eat outside or whatever yeah i feel like
guys like use the pandemic as an excuse
to just like sit on their couch
like i get a lot of that like when i
just come over and watch tv
i get that a lot and not the answer is
no by the way
the answer is fucking hard pass honestly
next time a guy does that copy and paste
my phone number and say text this person
if she has to talk to you
i will it happens a lot you're going to
be getting a lot of text in
i have a first three dates no sitting on
couches
yeah i know it's weird is it because
like they're scared to put effort in or
because they just don't want to or
because
at least they own a couch that's true
they own their own couch
i think there's a sloppiness i think
there's a
like a casual a trend towards casual
that i do not fuck with because my thing
is in the first three dates i'm not
looking for the way you're treating me
because i know how you're going to treat
me because i know you want i know what
you want
first three dates i want to see how you
treat service people i want to see how
you treat waiters
i want to see how you tip valets i want
to see the way you behave in the world
i want to see how you talk and order
food how you order like that's the kind
of stuff i'm looking for
i can't find that out at your fucking
house that's true you have no idea no i
have no idea
you know there's also a trend in like
not caring is cool now like if i just
don't care it's like so cool it's always
kind of been like that though but not
caring is not it's not cool no it's
it's lame it's uh ugly
and my thing is like i just don't i
don't think that
would be the pandemic makes it crazy but
you can still add a level of like
formality to even being at home like let
me cook you dinner or do you want to
cook dinner together do you want to
do this thing or like put some fucking
effort in yeah it's true i cooked dinner
with this guy that and i thought it was
so cute that he was like i'm going to
get all the ingredients and stuff
and let's like cook together but then
like you know in movies and stuff when
people cook together it's like it's cute
like they're talking the whole time
oh god yeah because they have a script
written for them they memorized lines
and they had people put the food out for
them
onions and cries because someone in post
production edit it so it looks like
they're talking
and like even if something goes wrong in
a movie like if if like the mac and
cheese is burnt
they laugh and they kiss like it doesn't
matter well
when i went over to this guy's house and
we were cooking it was like
he couldn't multitask so like anytime
i'd speak he'd be like
and i was like dude like you went out of
your way to like get all this stuff to
like hang out and like cook and
we can't even like talk and i didn't say
that i was thinking that
and he was just like literally every
time i tried to start a conversation
he'd just be like
a manchester america sweetheart
literally and he'd do it all the time
like we'd be watching something on tv
and he'd be like i oh we watched tiger
king which is like
not good but we watched it and basically
like
anytime i tried that's something you
talk during right like it's not like
you don't have to like seriously like
focus on that and he was like
shh every single time what you should
just laugh
i'll let you be alone my bad this is
making me crazy so
things being interrupted and then like
he was making a steak and he was like i
can't like i can't concentrate
because i was trying to like say
something to him and then it was so
weird and then we like sat there and we
ate basically in silence oh and he was
like how all he said was how's the steak
the entire time and i was because he
made it and i was like it's really good
and that was literally like the entire
that's the only time he doesn't want you
to stop talking
yeah when it's about him yes it was so
bad can i ask what he did for a living
or will that give it away
um no i don't he played tennis oh
athlete
oh yeah i mean come on yeah no athletes
no athletes athletes red flag that's a
red flag
do you want to go through you want to go
through some red flags okay so no
athletes
no ass bands no boy bands
no boys period no boy bands no
musicians no magicians magicians
no magicians musicians um
what else huh what if a guy says he's a
poet is that
but no can't like spoken word yeah
definitely not
no no no no no no that's nothing no
that's
a poet a poet people say they're a poet
because they want to have uh
kurt texts like i'm a poet sorry like
i'm an actor
this is i mean actors is a tricky one
they lie for a living they literally
get paid money for how good they are
at pretending and lying so
if you want to sign up for that godspeed
you're dating someone that wins awards
for how good they are
at duping people and lying to people you
know so
it's it's hard to trust an actor um
i also think that actors that work
ones at work or no more are the ones at
work so only date like bad actors
yes
you have to date bad actors that's the
only kind you're allowed to date so you
can tell when they're live
like watch they're real before you go
out with
um i don't here's the thing i don't like
judging people based on their job
because i don't like when people judge
me based on my job
like when they're like oh well she's a
female comedian she must be this this
this like that's true they're like
always exceptions too like you never
know
and that said i'm the first person that
when i'm in a fight with a guy i'm like
well i'm a female comic what do you
think was gonna happen
i do play that card but i don't like
when people play that card at me
because there is a very specific
neurology that
makes us the way we are so i thought of
something
when you came in today you made me
realize a red flag it is a red flag when
you go to someone's house
and they apologize about how much of a
mess their house is
even if their house is put together
because that's someone who is a
perfectionist
that you're never going to be able to
live up to their expectations perfection
is red flag you seem like you're really
on top of these red flags like
you've got them down in like a way
someone who loves red flags
but it's also a red flag when someone's
place is a mess like when you went to
that guy's house to play video games was
this house a mess
um it was like medium it wasn't terrible
it was like
it was okay it's also he told me his mom
came over and cleaned it like
okay that is the biggest red flag if
your mom is still cleaning your man's
house
yeah that happened but a good
relationship with mom is good
so i'm torn on that one because maybe
it's good she was there
i want him to have a good relationship
with his mom but i don't want her
cleaning his house
yeah that's just cleaning a lot every
time it looked nice yeah because then he
might expect you to clean his house
because he's used to women
that's true yeah no no no and so what is
the um
what is like if i'm gonna ask you out
what's the best thing i can possibly do
um best thing you can possibly do like
where do i take what do i do i take you
to dinner
oh yeah i'd probably want to go eat or
like i've been hiking a lot during the
pandemic
i probably want to go hike i feel like
that's good because you're like walking
and like doing something yeah it kind of
takes away from like the awkwardness and
if he's annoying you just push him off a
cliff yeah there's always that
um i like a hike date yeah it's not bad
i mean the only thing is you might get
like really sweaty and
that part's kind of gross but i think
that's good because for me it's like
i've spent so much of my life sort of
pretending to be one thing for a man
and then getting super resentful when i
the jig is finally up when i finally
have to like show him my face without
makeup or whatever so it's like i like
hiking it's like you're gonna see me
without makeup
that's true like you're gonna actually
like get through yeah and then you can
decide if you're in or you're out
but for me to put shellac caulk and
grout all over my face for three months
for you to then see what i actually look
like i
like just see it so hikes force me to do
that
you know don't take me to like a a dimly
lit restaurant for three months and then
and then take me on a hike it's gonna be
a jarring
it's gonna be jarring would that be like
the thing you'd wanna do like go hiking
or i don't know it's hard to think of
like a first thing to do with somebody
i feel like it's gonna be awkward no
matter what like a little bit i have to
be honest with you
the pandemic has made me start to i'm
into fucking face timing for a first
date that's true a lot of people are
doing that now i'm into it
we should have always been doing that we
never should have been meeting in person
what were we insane sometimes it's like
i feel like it's terrible though over
facetime and it's like not bad in person
do you think that's a thing well that's
because of how good your skin is
i would want to meet people in person
too if i look like you
actually i don't know i just feel like
sometimes like if you're talking on like
the phone that it's like a little more
uncomfortable like than being like right
next to the person or it's just
different or vice versa like sometimes
it's good over like talking on the phone
or texting and then when you meet the
person it's not good
especially with texting like have you
ever texted someone and they're like
really funny and then you put them in
person and they're like not funny at all
oh no is that what you're thinking about
this that was very pointed
you don't have me
oh my god um i here's the thing
i get so insecure in person
about you know like is this cute is that
my thong
right you know what i mean i might do my
boobs look good like
i like the idea of being in my own space
when i first meet someone because i can
actually become it takes the discomfort
out of the first date
you know the anxiety and the stress i
also like it because you can get a
little peek
into their house or apartment like right
away
i like to see inside people's homes
because the worst is when you go on
three dates with a guy
and then you go back to his house and
you're like oh my god
are you what you've got a a bill and
ted's excellent adventure poster on your
wall
if i had seen that and known about that
first date i never would have gone on
the second two like i'd like to see a
little
sneak peek of the and then because i'll
say like let me see
give me a little tour of your place and
then i'll see that he's oh that's like a
move that's like something easy i'll see
that he has black towels
psychopath only psychopaths have black
towels and you know this
and i'm correct so that's an opportunity
to sneakily get like a
a little tour of their place why are you
rolling your eyes
i was i looked away because i like that
i'm correct i just imagine you talking
like that on a date
you're a psychopath and i'm correct
i'm telling you i the first thing i need
to know about a guy is the color of
their towels
maybe that can be my bio yours is
correct
dude that's your opener dude every guy
that texts you what color your towels
if they say black block them huh i said
this should work great could you imagine
your first date yes with whitney bailey
all right so i have a couple questions
yes dude and
also people that get it fucking get it
well that's a good excuse i think that i
like
i like doing like i don't like small
talk i'm not good at small talk i only
like big talk and when you do like a
zoom date or a facetime date is your
first date you can get straight into the
big talk
like tell me about that urn full of your
grandmother's ashes behind you on the
bookshelf
i'd love to have a sprinkler where you
want to put her how did she die tell me
the details
like i like to just get into really like
let me see your medicine cabinet what
meds are you on
like really dive deep into yeah you
can't ride in the problem is the first
date is always just a fucking
performance where we're just lying and
it's just the greatest hits and you know
you're just sort of like
you know i just like to get right into
it brandon's like slowly backing out of
you helping her she's like i don't
really know
you know what actually i'm saying i kept
doing really well
no i'm up for the help no i think i use
it i think um
uh i think that's important i think just
getting to know someone online i'm very
pro that i think most people think i'm
anti that but i'm very
into it because the thing that annoys me
the most is when i put freaking pants on
and shoes and lip liner and deodorant
and the whole thing and i drive down and
you're fucking
i'm like i could have found this out
over text i could have avoided this
three-hour debacle if i just asked like
two more questions over text
there was a guy went out with and every
single time like it seemed like he was
about to kiss me i'd start talking about
my dead grandmother
it literally happened like three times
like i'd somehow work my grandma into
the conversation because i like
just i don't know why i like wasn't like
i knew he was about to kiss me and i
just like wasn't ready for it
and my mind is the worst because i was
just trying to make conversation but it
was like
every time it would just be like some
crazy stupid like thing that i hadn't
talked about in like 20 years
and it would be like horrible like it'd
be like about death or it'd be like
maybe that's what was turning him on i
don't think so
he like backed off real quick when i'd
like get into my spiels
about the difference was this a first
date no it was like maybe like the
eighth time i went out with this guy and
like every time it was like finally i
brought it up i said like i can't stop
like
like i just told him like i can't stop
bringing up my grandmother
it was bad one time i was talking about
it she played like balloon ball at the
rest home she lived at and she used to
not want to play balloon ball it was
actually really
cute like you said this to a man as he
was trying to kiss you yes i did oh my
god
see i told you i need help but um it
actually was cute though she used to
like love to
like she didn't want to play balloon
ball because she thought she was above
it but then once we'd like wheel her out
there she'd start playing
like when the ball got nearer she did it
she was like pissed about it well
because it was getting thrown at her i
don't think she was playing i think she
was trying to do no i think she was like
really
trying to get away from her she thought
she was above it
she was like reluctantly playing balloon
ball no because she was reluctant
she was being thrown at her
i'm
my dead grandmother playing balloon ball
you just abused your grandmother why
why why did you keep throwing a balloon
on her jesus christ is poor woman she
kept hitting it she didn't have to hit
it
if she did it was being thrown at her
it wouldn't have hurt her it would have
just dropped to the ground
it's a yeah balloon like
she said you're taking this memory from
me
oh my god i had the worst i want to say
this was like three years ago
when i first started dating on a dating
app and i went out with this guy
we went on a couple dates he came to my
house we had had like a couple glasses
of wine he followed me back to my house
from a restaurant that was it on animal
on fairfax so it was like
a good 20 minute drive when i lived in
studio city you told him he could follow
you back come here
to me yes because i drive separate i
don't drive in a car with you i can't
sit in the passenger seat i get to
like fancy and you'll um i i
got carsick i get um just more bossy
and bitchy tell him i have to like you
have to take a left here you're gonna
save time if you just take a right like
get in the other lane like i start
backseat driving to people i mean i
don't even have to know you to do it
if i if a guy drives me somewhere we
will be 10 years married on the first
date i'll just like you always do this
why are you
getting like you need to get over like
you're like i am the worst
so we drive separately i just know that
that's the only way i can keep men it's
actually attracted to me and i'm like
mysterious i drive alone like
um it's another power move just it's
it's to be like no no like i'll drive
like a power i know i'm always like well
i'm coming from work why don't i just
meet you there it's number one i have an
out and number two you don't have to see
me in the passenger seat because you
will never fall in love with me if you
do
so we're driving back we come back to my
house we play all the little games that
i talk about my book we play
your favorite you know um animal you're
the word association we're like playing
little games like on pieces of paper and
like laughing
we walk to the door i'm like okay he's
gonna kiss me
and he just goes all right dude
and i i i froze i it's very rare that
i'm speechless did he actually say dude
when he did it all right dude
what and i literally was like and he was
like what are you supposed to do
it was a like a fist bump like a
thing you know you have to like you know
guys like stick it for a minute
and you just have to feel it out i had
those secret handshakes yeah the weird
like was it like he was so nervous no it
was just like all right bro
i was like can't even if you're not
attracted to me why not just kiss me
just and then don't call me tomorrow
like it actually
would be just pretend you're attracted
to me
and then ghost me that way i say bro a
lot now are you sure that he was just
wasn't just saying it as like the button
at the end it was uncomfortable
and then someone told me later he is
friends with a friend of mine and they
uh they said to me oh he thought you
were too funny and he felt like
he couldn't date you because you thought
you were too funny he felt you were like
more of a friend
you can only be friends with people that
are funny i
i guess that is ridiculous and i
remember and it really fucked me up for
a while because i don't go and date
somebody i'd be like don't try to be
funny funny just be serious and just
listen and just laugh at their jokes and
you you know and then i was just and
then i got exhausted
that the whole point was to try to be
funny and it's like bad if it if you're
not
that goes i think more confused than
ever
[Laughter]
she came on the show she's like i'm more
confused than ever i came here for
clarity we came here to talk through
some stuff
i'm just more confused than ever i think
with the right person you don't have to
think about any of this shit that you
think
maybe because you took him home and you
started giving him those psychological
quizzes and he's like shouldn't have
scrabble or something
of life i made him drive 20 minutes
following me yeah and then you were like
what do you see in this in this picture
this workshop test i'm giving him
psychological tests he's like all right
i'm out
hey bro yeah i guess i can see how that
could maybe not be like super sexy
foreplay
um that was i i'm trying to think how
i've
ever first kisses are just such a
nightmare yeah they are you know what i
noticed
younger guys by younger i mean thirty
one younger guy and all of a sudden they
ask you uh
if they can kiss you that's a big thing
oh that's cute yeah consent is important
i know but or does it kind of ruin the
moment because it's like well
it's just it's just sort of like i don't
know can you bitch
like okay we can't go backwards everyone
like it's just like i'm
there's a lot in the news and consent is
important but also it's like
like can i take your broth i don't
fucking know can you
like i i can't be if i feel too alpha
in an intimate situation i can't be
attracted to you i it feels weirdly
maternal like
like mommy can i take your breath first
like jesus christ you just start
answering it really direct i don't know
it's kind of hard
like there's a class like i don't know
it might be difficult for you
could i say i should do it can i take
your brother it's a sports bra i have to
take it
i only wear sports no way you're going
to be able to get it off it's weird this
younger generation of men they ask
like like over asked like like can i do
this can i do this can i touch you here
could it and then they just want to put
their
penis in your butt and you're like jesus
christ like the morays have
changed dramatically i feel like at this
point
okay we're taking a break from the
heavenly
miranda cosgrove adore my best fiend
my best don't i think that's good she's
my new best fiend
your best fiend no my best fiend is the
game best fiends
it's such a fun game i've been playing
it for a long time have you started
playing it since then
literally playing right now if you're
watching this on youtube i'm currently
playing it as i'm trying to
i get so into this game it's like um
it's there's something like hypnotic
about it and there's something super
relaxing about it like i don't meditate
you guys know this about me i can't f
like i just like playing this game it
puts me in like a little
like trance you know it creates your
brain too you're like solving puzzles
yeah like there's something really
soothing that's why we're doing this a
lot i know um we love
this game is great it makes me want to
dance and like bob my head like it's
just there's something really soothing
about it and
you know we're in a pandemic and we
don't get to go out and do as many fun
things as we want to these days
but um thank god for this it's super fun
so basically what you do is you
like collect all these little friends
like these forest creature friends
they're so cute
like a lizard and a spider and there's a
little bobby
which you know i love bees there's a bee
with one eyeball that's a spider
oh it looks like a bee it's a spider
it's yellow
i think it's a yellow jacket it's not a
yellow that is a yellow jacket it is a
spider i know because i saved its lives
look at the far right that's a
yellowjacket it's a spider it's a spider
spiders aren't yellow i know because
they told me as a spider when i saved it
is he a legend anyways you get to
collect all these friends and you're
against these like slugs these monstrous
slugs
that are mad they're real mad and you
basically have to solve like puzzles and
problems
and then you fight the slugs and you
collect more friends along the way
it's just like i don't know there's
something it's just it's like it
it's very soothing but it's not you know
what most games make me angry
it doesn't make me angry i don't know
it's fine i don't ever get frustrated
i'm not like
like i'm gonna look juice like it
doesn't make me feel bad about myself
it doesn't like piss me off it's just
like so soothing and fun to play
and you can play it with friends i got
three strawberries you can play it with
friends and family
there's currently over 100 million
downloads
wow that's wild wow that's incredible
yeah it's unique and exciting
it updates every month with new levels
and events so it never really gets
oh i got a strawberry
it never gets old
it doesn't require internet to play
that's amazing you don't have to worry
about wi-fi
or using cell data that's a game-changer
you can collect the cutest little
characters upgrade them they grow as you
as you level them up i love
my little dragon i love them so engage
your brain with fun puzzles and collect
tons of cute characters which characters
are my you're all three of them
not the black snail no that's the slug
that we're against
oh she just started guys
trust me with over a hundred million
downloads this five steps
look look i got the thing i got the
fuzzy man want to hate those
you only have this many moves left and
you've only heard him that bad
you're mean i'm a mean gamer
engage your brain with fun puzzles and
collect tons of cute characters trust me
with over 100 million downloads this
five star
five star rated wow mobile puzzle game
is a must play
download best fiends free on the apple
app store or google play
that's friends without an r best fiends
okay i'm not even reading the copy for
manscaped benton you can surprise
surprise
but i want you guys to know dead serious
i use this manscaped
nose hair trimmer before we film every
time all
every day i love it so much you just use
it
and look do you hear the little crackles
if you're not watching on youtube
well i just shaved it yesterday so
there's nothing it's truly how fast do
your nose hairs grow i know really fast
this is embarrassing
and sometimes i actually use it to do my
eyebrow hairs up here
if if you cut through your eyebrow right
now in this ad
it would show how great the product is
manscaped there's a brand dedicated to
helping men feel self-confidence
through body image it is a known fact
that females are attracted to men who
show confidence
that is correct
i i co-sign that
data have you ever seen an untrimmed
bush how do you feel about that
it's like i don't think you guys
understand i hope i'm allowed to say
this
uh it also it's it's
it's greasy it's gives us
razor burn like you're untrimmed
unmanscaped
scrotum gives us rashes
carpet burn ingrowns the willies
bumps and bruises frankly the ookies
and it's it's if
can i say something really crass if you
want us to suck your dick you got to
shave your balls
there i said it you have to make your
body
inviting for us you have to make it
something
we want to uh climb you have to make it
something we want to jump all over and
rub our bodies on
so the product is good
the manscape perfect package 3.0 is the
perfect package for your perfect package
they wrote that i love it i know
manscaped has redesigned the electric
trimmer and called it the lawnmower 3.0
i think what i shaved my head with but
it worked so good it went through all
that hair i know that you guys are
listening going
oh but i'll just use a regular razor no
you won't okay because then you're going
to put your leg up on the tub you got to
pull your balls apart like chicken feet
[Music]
and then then you shave against the
grain and then
you're bleeding you end up getting razor
burn and then i think it's herpes
and that's the other thing and if you
cut your balls you're not calling the
paramedics you'll bleed to death
you'll be so embarrassed so use an
actual product designed for this your
skin is thinner down there we all know
that
you know it's not hot a band-aid on your
balls
have you pulled down someone's pants
they had a band-aid on their nut sack
you like oh
or just like a little piece of tissue
yeah that's what you guys do when you
cut your
cut is still shaving you put a little
tissue like as if we can't see it
what is that so there's the crop
preserver which is a deodorant for your
balls which
you all fucking need okay y'all need it
and if you're a girl listening
your man needs it just purchase it crop
mops
go to wipes if you don't have time to
shower okay you can carry these around
and just wipe your balls if you don't
have time to go in the shower just do
what you can
okay crop reviver is a testicle toner
we'll give you a little pep in your step
help you smell insanely good and this
isn't necessarily for you
sir it's for us you heard me it's for us
it's the least you can do you see all
the products i have my bathroom how many
products i have in my bathroom
130 about 136 you can buy
four manscaped products sticky balls are
over you can do
four products okay it's not that hard uh
the perfect package will also come with
a travel kit and a pair of
manscape boxer briefs that will keep
your junk filling fresh all day
hey hey you know what after you use this
we won't call it junk anymore
because it'll smell so good we'll call
it family jewels
start calling it an aromatic gift
caught your prized hog
why do people call it a hog
um get 20 off in free shipping with code
whitney20 at manscape.com
for the ladies listening well i don't i
agree we do not want pubes in our mouths
i mean that's they just said it right
here i i thought it was
too crass to say that but it's true we
don't you ever have a pube stuck in your
tooth it's a nightmare
you get a it's not good for a job
interview either it looks horrible
not even the not even the paris filter
can hide that get 20
off and free shipping with code
whitney20 manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
and youth code whitney20 we're not even
advertising this product i don't think
in this ad but this is the nose hair
trimmer we never have been
get that too oh have we no we're not
getting paid to talk about this but this
is an unbelievable product
get pleasured the right way and use
manscape yes
and then i'm trying to think what else
are you struggling with in terms of
dating online
um let's see i guess just dating in
general i've had like a series like a
string of very bad
like dates like for years like maybe
like seven or eight years she's like
it's been a long time
every single time i go on um on it like
maybe two three dates it like just
goes terribly like it was sort of like a
joke between me and like one of my
friends for a while because it's like
you can't make it past like three
without something going wrong
but basically like well i went out with
this one guy and when he went to kiss me
he
bit me and he like first time he ever
kissed me like he bit my lips
it was bleeding like actual blood was
coming off my lip
and then i was like holding kleenex to
my lip and he was apologizing and
wait was he trying to do it like in a
sexy way yeah like to be yeah
that's what he was trying to do and drew
blood yeah he like bit my lip pretty
hard
so cute and this is so cute
and actual yeah so anyway like it was
like a paper cut on my lip and it
wouldn't stop bleeding and i was
standing there and it was really
uncomfortable
do you have braces oh no he didn't have
braces
he was trying to be in a boy band though
but um yeah that was bad and then i i
guess that was kind of on me like i just
felt like it was so uncomfortable i
never saw him again
like i just from then on out like i was
just like i can't like so
awkward it was just so weird for like 30
minutes like standing there like trying
to make small talk with him like
apologize
as a man your only job is to not
cut me your only job on the date is to
make sure i'm not bleeding at any point
and you couldn't do you had one job yeah
it was it was weird literal red flag
that's a red flag
draws blood red flag i mean i think it's
nice like you seem
like you're such a clear person like you
vibrate on like such a pure authentic
way
i think that you probably end up people
reveal themselves to you sooner which is
actually a good thing
i hope that'd be great you know like you
see things like my brain would go oh my
god he cut my lip like this is the
perfect wedding story
like my brain is a funny story like if
it had been a really good match that
would have been like a good story
i'd be like oh my god you cut my lip
this would be like so funny in a
romantic comedy and like i'm gonna tell
the story of my wedding and then i would
like make the relationship work just so
that that was my wedding story
so you just go on for like five years
and then he's like i can't just have
this great story with someone and then
not like
have it work out like this is how it's
supposed to end yeah it was kind of it
could have been charming i
also have like this belief that if you
like meet somebody and they're really
the right person like you probably would
just think anything they did was like
great like you wouldn't i feel like i'm
like looking for reasons to like
maybe like not make it work like as soon
as that happened i was like oh this
can't work
yeah you're just like looking for an out
yeah like maybe if you know it's not the
right fit or like
i'm so torn on that miranda i'm torn on
that because i think
you know i i there's two schools of
thought which is like
the cap off the toothpaste like it's
really annoying
unless it's the person that you love in
which case it's gonna be adorable you
know
but i think everyone that you're sort of
you know your brain is flushed with
oxytocin and
dopamine in the beginning like that's
gonna wear off like the thing that's
super cute in the beginning
yes the thing that's super cute in the
beginning is gonna become annoying
and when do we accept it and when do we
say
get the fuck out of here with that shit
and it's really hard for me to tell the
difference because
i can be such a perfectionist and
what not say anything good um
and you didn't see that the problem and
i never know like it's very hard to tell
where healthy boundaries
and healthy tolerance and forgiveness
like how to balance those two things you
know
yeah like what's actually like what's
worth fighting for and what's not and i
think it's about it being worth it
you know is this person worth it this is
fucking annoying but like you know i
remember someone saying to me a very
wise woman who's been
thrice married uh she said to me once
something that i know i don't know if i
believe in it or not
and i think it depends on where you are
in your life and if you want to get
married and if you want to have kids and
what you want i think it's different for
everyone but she said i'm
if you can get 80 of what you want go
for it
like that's like that's a match 80
percent of what you want that reminds me
of how people say like if you have one
good friend in your whole life you did
pretty well
yeah i love that i love that i feel like
they mostly say that to famous
uh stars like you i feel like that's a
celebrity thing too
one is actually a lot one is a lot for a
celebrity
um so it's like for me it's like i'm
always in this area of like what do i
where do i settle and where do i not
like what's like too much and what's
like
the right amount and i think that for me
the biggest thing isn't about
what's the thing you compromise on
what's the thing you settle on it's
you're gonna constantly
be compromising it's how quick can you
recover so
i have so many notes i'm such a i am
such a high bar for what
i allow in my house and in my life i
have to be able to say
i don't like when you do that i don't
think you do that can you and then then
be able to receive it
course correct and recover and not have
resentment about it
so that's that's the thing i need the
most that seems like a really hard thing
to do
like to be able to get over someone with
no ego yeah you'd have to be like
a real good because you're in a constant
state of negotiation
there's no it's like it's like um
there's gonna there's no you're never
gonna find the perfect house you never
find the perfect person
you're gonna have to do work on it right
you're gonna have to do work on yourself
to make it a better fit
so for me it's always like just about
like can we work through conflict well
together
it's scary though because sometimes like
even i don't know if this has ever
happened to you but like even if you
hang out with like your best friend but
you're stuck with them for like
a week straight yeah by the end of the
week you're like driving you're driving
yeah like like things that you never
noticed are happening and like you're
driving them crazy and you're driving
you crazy so yeah
i feel like it would be really hard to
live with somebody and try to make it
work
you know what it is it's like it's like
someone who isn't too sensitive like you
just made me realize like
one of my best girlfriends we've spent a
lot of time together but i'll be like
i'm gonna go for a walk alone and she's
like got it
like she's and there's no like well what
do you do you don't want me to come like
well why don't i
go you don't want there's none of that
shit you know i can't have someone who's
too sensitive
yeah who's going to take things too
personally you know have you lived with
someone
um only my parents
it's really hard yeah it's not easy so
you live with your parents now because
you had like a trauma well i technically
i start i went back and started saying
with my parents during the quarantine
and i have like an insane amount of
animals and they
my mom will like help me take care of
them because i started fostering a bunch
of animals like during the
quarantine and it's been like really fun
i have the two bugs i was telling you
about but um
but anyway yeah it's just like it's kind
of like i sort of feel like um a little
kid whenever i'm like at my parents
house because it's like i have the same
bedroom i had ever since i was little
like they live in the same house they've
always lived in
so it's a little weird like to be there
but um
then i have like my own place too but
i've just been staying there a lot
um like because of the quarantine and
hanging out with them
it's been kind of fun like to be with
them but also
it has its moments they aren't great do
you find i i find that when
you know we we grow and we become adults
and we mature and as soon as i get
with my mom i become 14 again yeah
that's like exactly what it's like
it's like time travel back into it yes
and i'm like mom
and i'm like i'm 37 years old i know
it's totally like that like my mom will
like comment on like she'll like try to
help me pick my outfit before i leave
i'm like oh my god
what is happening it's frightening a
little bit
um but yeah but it's nice to be around
them but yeah a crazy thing happened at
my
my house and it sort of like made me
want to go stay with him
a while for a while because um this like
it was really weird but i went on a bad
date and i was at the arc light like
seeing a movie with somebody
he was wearing zebra pants and like just
walked in first time i ever met him like
straight up zebra pants
no it was kind of cool like pajama pants
no they were like they were like regular
like zebra jeans like
regular zebra jeans like that's a thing
you know you know these are the regular
zebra jeans it's like average zebra
jeans like you know as people
do okay he was really into my space um
and he i think there was like a chain
hanging from one side too but um
anyway so we saw uh some movie and then
uh afterwards it was raining and it like
it never hardly ever rains in l.a so
i was i was kind of like i don't want to
go back to my place even though my place
is pretty close dark white
and um anyway i went to my parents house
and then i got a call
at like three in the morning that
somebody had like died at my
house and it was the weirdest thing ever
because they had like caution tape
up and you know like it was right in my
front yard and basically
i guess a guy came and he was like
burying things in my backyard for like
three days
and um he buried a lunch box with like a
milk chocolate inside of it
in my backyard and then he buried like
knives and like a rope
and like a bunch of random stuff and i
guess he'd been in my backyard like
hanging out there and like bearing
things why i didn't notice i don't know
and i'm just like apparently not very
observant
and then um i found out later that like
all that stuff was there and that he had
been like pacing in my backyard with a
gun
he also looked like crazy like he was
wearing like this long trench coat and
he had like a
still dressed better than your date in
the zebra pants yeah he was dressed
pretty nicely um but yeah he was just
like pacing in my backyard i guess
and because i have like security cameras
so later when we looked i
we figured out he was back there for
like like six hours or something like
waiting
and then somebody drove up that had a
similar car
like that kind of looked like my car and
i guess he got confused and he thought
that maybe it was me driving up it's
just like bad luck
and he like shot at this person like six
times and he missed because she was in a
car
she drove away and then he set himself
on fire
and he shot himself simultaneously
and then later so i gotta call it like
three or four in the morning this
happened probably at like one in the
morning i gotta call it like three or
four in the morning
saying like where are you like can you
come like
to your house because someone like
killed themselves there
and they were trying to just like put it
all together and they still haven't
really put
like put it all together why it happened
or like what the person was doing or if
he
it might have just been totally random
like he saw me somewhere and he like
followed me
home and then or something like that but
anyway they never figured out like
exactly exactly why
so um but yeah so it freaked me out
really bad and i started staying
like back at my parents house and then i
got another house somewhere else because
i
felt like it was should we share the
address yeah i should probably tell the
address to that house
i mean how are you
what like are you do you need some
lunesta do you need sleeping pills i
have some like the only thing i know to
say to you is like i
have sleeping pills of ambien like
how do you cope with something like that
it was really like just bizarre but i
kind of do like i have like a fantasy of
like
diving into the story and like figuring
out like exactly
why it all like happened just because i
think it'd be interesting to know like
who the person was and like why they
were there and exactly
what was going on right right yeah i
don't know if i'd make it worse or if
they'd make it better but it just
seems like it'd be kind of interesting
to have like more answers like i've
never um
obviously had something that traumatic
but from what i have learned um
uh gavin to becker who's i talk about
all the time in this podcast the book
the gift of fear
uh which is i i don't know if you should
read it or not have you read it
no why i don't know if you i mean it's
all about
this it's about sort of like you know
how women have developed a sixth sense
and how we can sort of like
you know feel if we're in danger and how
we need to honor that intuition
and you know how we um sort of doubt
ourselves and
and demean our own gut instinct now
because we've been told for so long that
we're crazy and that we need to calm
down and that we're psycho and we're
emotional and we're dramatic and we're
sensitive and
whatever and that we have the sixth
sense where
we can go like i have a weird feeling
about that person you know when you're
in public or whatever just automatically
know a lot of the time you just know and
it's like there's no reason for it i
can't articulate why necessarily but i'm
telling you have a weird feeling about
and that celebrities in particular and
by celebrity i don't just mean actresses
like anyone who has any kind of power
you know you can be a celebrity in your
local town because you own the bread
shop you know like anyone
that has like attention coming at the
bread shop that's a thing some
places
what lifetime movie is that i know she
dropped her french bread in romantic
comedies there's always like one
long french bread coming out of the
groceries that's like totally not
wrapped
for some reason i'm always looking real
fresh this isn't
france in the 20s
and so i'm like obsessed just as like in
making television i'm obsessed with the
prop guy that was like here's the bread
like they just put that there's this
one loaf of bread that's been in every
movie it's been more
famous more than any actor on the planet
and um and basically how you know we
developed this sixth sense and and and
we doubt it you know
um and just like the it's called the
gift of fear and about how important
fear is okay
and there's all these incredible stories
and by incredible i mean like horrifying
of women that have been stalked and
stuff and um who is the woman
sorry i don't want to traumatize you
further i'm saying it worse
oh my god i already ruined your memory
with your grandmother it's okay
this is a nightmare but it's a lot about
the psychology of
stalkers and the the psychology of
obsession i actually love that kind of
stuff like i'm really interested in like
i love watching like
shows about murders and like how they
happened and all that yeah and a lot of
it
a lot of that fascination is our brain
when we're scared uh preparing
and studying and doing recon and
research basically which is the same
reason we have nightmares like people
there's a war on nightmares
uh and i will not have it nightmares are
good so are you gonna be able to live
alone at some point you think
um yeah i do i mean i have another place
and i do stay there sometimes and stuff
but like
i need to get you some dogs we need some
big dogs yeah that'd be good they say
the best security system in the world is
dogs
they say that the bark is all that
matters too that's right that's right
yeah like if the dog has a really good
bark yes the bite helps too
that's true but my dog has like this
really like great bark even though she
weighs like 14 pounds
but now i just gave it away so yeah yeah
you get a really big yeah we need to get
you like
like a serious dog all my friends were
like making fun of me
saying like you got to move out like
come on like because it was funny
because when the thing happened with the
guy at my house
like it was raining that night so i went
back to my parents house like i didn't
even go home to my house
i love that this guy's so dumb he set
himself on fire then one day it rains in
l.a
i know the one day you can't catch a
good fire how does a person shoot
themselves and set them
like how do they even do that so they
haven't even like done the forensics on
how he did it
well they figured out who this is a man
who's good at multitasking
and then it was crazy too they found
like his car like a few blocks away and
there was like blood and like hair in
the trunk
and they were like oh he's probably a
serial killer but they never figured out
exactly like
like the story and he was like taking
trips do we not pay enough taxes in
california
why have they not dug deeper into this
investigation i think they tried like
they tried to dig really deep they even
went they went to where he lived and
like he only had a mattress and like
white walls
and they and nothing on his computer and
they they couldn't like figure out
anything
how old was he maybe like late 30s wow
yeah but he took care of the problem so
doesn't it seem fun though to try to
like
maybe not fun but like interesting to
like try to figure out yes i love the
psychology of stuff like this like what
was going on
bits and pieces but are you
have you like built a sort of like
exoskeleton of armor
or have you cried about this no i didn't
cry or anything but i just
it's because when are you gonna cry
about this did i cry right at one point
you dried up ass menthol stick i mean
this is traumatizing are you like is
there like denial denial is good i don't
want to take your denial from you it's a
very helpful tool
i mean i just think because i wasn't
actually there that night it helped a
lot because it's like
if i didn't actually experience like i
almost feel worse for the person who was
like i do feel worse so the woman who
are i mean that must have been horrible
i never like met her or spoke with her
but
that was probably really scary like
could you imagine being in a car and
like all of a sudden someone's like
shooting at your unless she was stalking
you also
while she was driving by to stop you
your other stalkers shot your other
soccer they're competing over your
your burying in your backyard but you
really do tell this story so like
nonchalantly you're just like he was
burying things in my backyard there was
blood in here in the car
milk chocolate bar weirds me out like by
the way that's good
i'm just trying to like the horizon
figure you out and you're
the biggest detail that you have
emphasized was there was
milk chocolate you're like i'm a dark
chocolate person
who eats milk chocolate ew that's the
thing that is the most offensive to you
about this whole story i mean
it's weird though like all the other
things add up like rope and knives and
things but like
milk chocolate killing people with a lot
of work you just snagged
and when you have a little treat before
he murdered you yeah like what is that
about
so that house are you gonna sell
probably yeah for a long time though i
kept it because i kept thinking like oh
like i'll get over it and i'll probably
go stay there but
to be honest even before that happened
it's like a very creaky house like in
the middle of the night like you hear
sounds and it seems like like people are
in the house because it's an older home
uh-huh
so i think i was already like not gonna
have the nerve to yeah there even before
that happened so i'm probably gonna
like move on and just so you own two
homes i'm putting that in the tinder bio
i own two homes oh my god
own two homes dodged death dodged to
death
dodge death and what was that rainy
early night
um no zebras pants please zebra pants
with a change so what do you want
like i look at someone like you and i'm
just like amazing family
amazing life i have this theory this is
a hot take that the fact that you had
such a traumatic horrible thing
happening
what are the chances that would happen
again that's true that's the thing i
said about the house the shoe dropped
the when something horrible happens to
me i get so excited because i'm like it
happened
i lived and it's not gonna happen again
my uncle was really disturbed because
when my dad died i was like whoa
okay that means my mom's not gonna die
for a while and he was like what i was
like it's just there's no way what are
the chances
it's like too bad of luck yes there's
like a little bit of a relief that
um uh sort of envelops me when something
really horrible happens because it makes
me think i have a couple years of like
serenity ahead of yeah because you sort
of know like something's bound to happen
eventually
yeah and then you get your breaks yeah
so now you so no one's going to try to
kill you for at least another couple
years
it happened like a few years ago so it
might be coming up to like yeah i was
gonna say actually
it might not be good for me so what do
you want in life do you want marriage
you want kids
um i think so but i've babied sad a few
times and that's it's never gone very
well but people always say it's
different when it's
when it's your kids yeah but i don't
know if that's i don't know
i think i know a lot of kid people that
think their own kids are annoying too
yeah i think people i know a lot of
parents are like it's worse when it's
your kids because
they owe you and they still act like
that you feed them and you give them
your body and you
look like you a little yeah they still
have great nerve to be an asshole yeah
you made them and they still treat you
like shit whenever i babysat though i
always try to be like
like i want to be fun and i want them to
think that i'm like
and then it never goes well like if
you're really fun with kids they don't
listen to a word you say yeah that's
right
it's all about respect yeah and it's
crazy because it's like it's really hard
to gain it like from a child
like it's like next to impossible my
friend had a kid like in high school and
it was so
hard like to get that kid to like me
like i would just like every time he
came around i felt like a lot of like
stress like to try to get him to like me
like i just wanted him to think i was
like
fun to be around i kept taking him to
disneyland and he'd be like how many
rides do we have to go
like he just literally it was so hard to
like win the kid over
you know what my nightmare is benton not
being able to take a nap every three
hours
my nightmare is not being able to have a
nightmare
because i'm not sleeping that is true oh
that's really sad
all i want in life is to have a
nightmare i have so much trouble
sleeping
you know this about me we've talked
about it every doctor
in l.a knows about you how many times a
day do i nap
a good seven sleep is the most important
thing to me
you guys ask me about my skin you ask me
about how i work so hard people ask
sleep is literally the secret to being
healthy and prolific we will be we'll
just carry on groceries and go back i
need to take a nap
i take naps it's just it's a lot on me
and i am like the princess and the pee
with mattresses oh god
thank god we have this one now this
helix
it sounds so addy the way we just it
does but but seriously
thank god this came in didn't we take a
quiz
yeah we took the quiz you take a helix
quiz they tell you the exact matches
that'll work for you based on what you
like
it's a very easy quiz we took it
actually on here one time oh that's
right for you
thank god very specific i like a hard
mattress
that is tempur-pedic i like a what i
call luke hard
yes i mean it's the it's truly the
greatest invention for you because the
amount of text you've sent where you're
like have you ever used this mattress as
if i'm just trying out mattresses left
right
you got a helix i got a helix yeah which
one did you get i got the super
soft the it's like really really soft
like uh but it's dense so you kind of
like
fall into it ah because i like to be
swaddled you look as good as hey you
want to feel like your mattress is
attacking you from behind like it could
choke me today
[Laughter]
i want to sleep on fuzzy pavement
because i sleep on my back that's my
tinder name i can i cannot stand
mattresses where you move around and
then the whole bed moves around
the helix mount it just remember because
i i almost changed this bed frame oh it
was a saga it was a saga
i made benton we carried mattresses in
didn't we post the video of us
yeah we so many matches also this
mattress is packaged so well
it comes right to your door i could
carry it by myself
this mattress you open it and it blooms
before your eyes yeah
like a lotus in the night it's quite
spiritual experience to watch it grow
in front of you yeah when he laid on it
while it did it which it does not
recommend but it worked anyways
uh oh well okay so we're giving it all
these compliments but people already
know it
uh because it was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine two very
snobbish publications
go to helix.com whitney take their
two-minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized uh
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life look at me look at me
no eye bags
i mean i probably have some eyeliner
bleeding down that's different that's
different that's a different thing
that's
a bad childhood not bad sleep they have
a 10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred
nights risk free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it
but you will love it i'm obsessed helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.comwhitney
can i tell you something do it
if it wasn't for doordash during this
quarantine i think i would have starved
to death by now
yeah you really would have like normally
you talk about like
podcast sponsors and we talk about how
much we love them
but truly doordash has kept me alive
like this george i'd be dead without
door down i haven't cooked anything in
months i don't think that's an
exaggeration i think truly
this is a life or death situation and
doordash
i'd like to just thank you for
sustaining my existence you're a hero
i order from doordash truly three meals
a day
i'm going through my order history for
those of you that think
i'm exaggerating look on the youtube i'm
holding up all my orders
zancoo chicken was my last order joey
restaurants joey restaurants
home italian eatery the six this was in
like three days by the way
joey restaurants i'm a i'm a creature of
habit they're great well because what i
do is you order something and then you
can just go back and reorder the same
thing
yeah they bring the food you're craving
right to your door versailles i ordered
some cuban food
california chicken cafe because i wanted
you know
and if you don't eat the same restaurant
over and over they also have 300
000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada and australia
the cheesecake factory which health nut
and then they do these special offers
health nut volcano
so i'm looking oh there's a bunch of new
ones on here now yeah updating all the
time can you read the facts because i'm
many of your favorites ordering food
many of your favorite local restaurants
are still open for delivery just open
doordash and select your favorite local
restaurant and the food will be left to
church
cheeto hot cheetos your favorite ah you
can order from 7-eleven
i do that all the time i heard from
7-eleven truly i do it to the point
where it's disgusting i'm like what's
wrong with me
look door dash doesn't judge they will
bring you whatever food you order
without judgment
especially because now they have
contactless delivery so no one can look
me in the eyes
they leave it at my door and i i watch
out the people for them to leave and
then i'm like
okay i open the door and i grab it
really quick nothing to do with coven
yeah i grab it really quick
go back in my house just wearing a black
robe
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of 15
or more and zero delivery fees for their
first month when you download the
doordash app and enter code whitney
ooh fishbone seafood is that the catfish
place oh my god yes i ordered that here
when you
weren't here that time and i was just
here um i ordered this and it is
i struggle with finding any good
southern food
in la you guys are like a joke but
literally
that is delicious okay benton's like
i just ordered catfish on doordash i'm
like save it for the ad
yeah they have hush puppy very good
anyways that's five dollars off your
first order and zero delivery fees for a
month when you download the doordash app
on the app store and enter code
whitney don't forget that's code whitney
for five dollars off your first order
with doordash
hush puppies they do have hush puppies
yeah they do what is a hush puppy
do you think that um uh you had your
childhood taken from you
um i don't feel like i had my childhood
taken from me i don't either but i
feel no sympathy for me of your grandma
just yet that i did just today
on this podcast i i just like i don't
know i think that i mean look
hollywood's obviously a very dangerous
place for a lot of reasons check my
twitter
um but i just think that uh that that
there's just like this thing where they
want everyone wants child stars to be so
like abused and it's like a we i almost
feel like it's weird a weird fetish
they're like most people's childhoods
are like some bad things like a disaster
all childhoods are a fucking disaster at
least you got to film it and got paid
yeah and like people always say um i
don't know like is it weird for you
because you didn't go to like middle
school or high school which
i guess is weird but like i was around a
lot of kids when i was
like it was still like oh that's right
you had a lot of kids on the show yeah
if you're
in on a tv show when you're that young
is there like therapy do they like make
you go to counseling
that's such a good idea like why don't
they have that so good i mean maybe they
do now but
no like when i was on a show i didn't
like they never
they weren't like let's get ahead of
this no they were like if that person's
having like a hard time like
ride them out of a few scenes so they
can take a break
and then like hopefully they'll like
walk it off
take a walk around the sound stage shake
it shake it off
oh that's so funny hopefully
she'll make it back
go to the makeup trailer put some put
some makeup on her see if that fixes her
self-esteem issues
change your outfit maybe it'll be it's
really what the fuck do you have to
complain about i mean like what do you
need a counselor for
and a tv show so you don't seem like you
get very insecure
i mean i'm definitely insecure about
something yeah like what
um i'm not good at math i'm terrible at
math
oh i don't know like i can't tell you
north south east or west like
when people ask me like where do you
live like in relation to where we are
now i i couldn't tell you like
that's anyone that's doing that to you
is like first of all don't tell anyone
where you live
you shouldn't you're someone blew
themselves up in front of your house so
when someone asks you where you live
don't answer even if you know the answer
okay this is some sort of like darwinian
strength that your brain has figured out
how to not tell people where you live
because of a trauma so i think that's
very intentional on your amygdala's part
yeah but i couldn't tell you totally
like so do you know like when you
i mean i don't want to break if i ask
you where disneyland was
do you know where that is in comparison
to where we are uh okay
now now
i'm i am terrible at uh uh
north south east west but i am also
terrible at being wrong i will not allow
myself to be wrong so my need to be
right is going to eclipse my
inability to you and then you're gonna
learn it and then
now my ego's getting involved well you
can go that way i mean you can
no it's south oh yeah that's what i'm
gonna do you could just i mean you could
figure out a way i would go i would go
to east and you go south i go well you
can go east and then south like that's
exactly what i would do if you make a
circle do you sleep well
no i sleep terribly really like five in
the morning and do what
i watch tv what do you watch um stuff on
netflix
i just watched kissing booth too oh yeah
how was that it was great i really
enjoyed there was some drama with them
on twitter
really i didn't know about the drama
yeah i gotta get into it i don't know i
only know the drama i don't know the
actual
product i just know this like spits
batting on twitter yeah i just like to
watch like random
movies do you have any like oh shit's
creek i just amazing
so good happy birthday dan levy was his
birthday was yesterday
he was our first podcast guest that's so
cool i love him um and so
let me ask you something is there anyone
like that you get like a crush on
because here's my problem with if i was
you most people can get crushes on
celebrities you could actually
like date them if you wanted to does
that get
confusing um i've never like
had a crush or i've never like been in
that situation where i met anybody that
was like
like harry styles like that'd be great
but no that's never happened
for me where is he why can't you date
him i don't know where he is
i'm gonna get on that blouse
i will get the i'm gonna make that
happen i met harry styles once um
how'd that go i think it went well
actually i'm not this is going to sound
like such a weird brag i think he
watched
he because the show i did was like
bigger in england i think maybe than
here and he like knew me and i was like
who are you and he's like
and they were like he's in a what's it
called one direction
he's in a band called four west i don't
know what it's called um up north
quest what's it called and yeah he's in
a boy band no
you can't date him or isn't he solo now
yeah he's stolen
okay okay that works so but but no
musicians we're not doing that they
travel too much
yeah they need someone that's going to
be around you need like a fireman
a fire yeah i'm glad you have animals i
think it's important for
people that are um have a lot coming at
them like i feel like you were
like they ground you like yeah you were
forced to be probably precocious you
were probably
forced to be an adult at a very young
age which a lot it's that's a big thing
with i think i would imagine child
starves but also what i identify as
adult child of alcoholics is like you
had to be an adult very young you had to
like cook dinner you had to handle
yourself you had to be on time you had
to like
put on the coffee like i feel like you
were you have a job but yeah like yeah
until you're like five years old and
you're like pouring bailey's in the
coffee you know like
and uh and it's so good to have animals
around because they bring out your like
childish side like you get to be a kid
with them you don't have to perform for
them they don't need anything from you
they don't want anything they just love
you
like it's so funny to me that your dogs
don't know who you are
yeah they couldn't care like your dogs
like aren't impressed by you don't care
like that's so funny to me the idea of
you like singing in your shower with
your amazing voice like your hits and
it's like oh can we go
clean up my shit mom i also have three
cats that i didn't mention but i thought
that i should probably leave
them out it's getting up there i
actually have one more animal
than the legal women i was saying if
animal control listens to this podcast
you're going to get rated
that's definitely going to happen to me
yeah you are a hoarder what animals do
you have
uh are you asking or is the county
asking it's a revolver are you going to
get rid of the door
um yeah it's a revolving door i have
three dogs is like
my max of that i have but then i foster
oh
a bunch all the time and then i have
like a pig oh my god so stupid
it's so interesting the dogs the breeds
that were attacked
uh attracted to and what that says about
us like you love that breed now i love
pugs now and i never
you were but you weren't a pug person
like at all before and now everyone
hug i'm oh my god it's the cutest thing
i've ever seen it's so weird the way
breeds choose you like i was a pitbull
person because i was like okay they're
misunderstood
people think that they're really
dangerous but they're actually really
sweet and scared which is was like
me in my 20s just like all bark no bite
i was like the roast girl who was like
so
tough but i was just like really sweet
and i just wanted someone to love me but
i like had a reputation for
that was like off-brand kind of thing
like i put out something that wasn't you
know a lot of false advertising
which is the same with pits right and uh
and so i like really connected to them
emotionally
and then this one sharpay that i rescued
i mean sharpays are like the pitbulls of
china they were bred to fight they were
bred sort of very
similarly yeah which is why they have
such wrinkly faces so the blood can drip
off them and they can continue fighting
wow
they're a little more solitary like
sharpay's like are sort of also
um bred to be was kind of obsessed with
one person like protect one person
they're not
was kind of yeah that's how chihuahuas
are because pit bulls are like i love
you and i love you and i love you and i
love everyone
you know which is like pays are like a
win sharper like focused on you violet
was obsessed with me and that was it
if anyone else tried to fuck with her
she was just like not interested
remember
yeah she loved you yeah
she i mean but they you have to be
careful when you foster them because
they
they bond and they get very attached
very quickly and it's very hard to get
them home afterwards so the last one i
just had
was her name tulip uh fiona i don't know
it's always yeah yeah no the last one
was fiona
oh you had another last foster i just
had oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so bambi bambi that was before that
you've had a lot of fun i know this is
like
uh it's like all names from shrek it's
like fiona baby it's like disney movie
um and uh and no fiona the one that i
just had
uh you know i i not only do i know i'm
gonna get attached quickly so i have to
turn them over because i just
you know you're just when you foster
you're just breaking your own car in a
few weeks it's like you're signing up to
just shatter your own heart over and
over again right so um
but also they get so bonded to you so
the first time i tried to get violeta
home
uh the one before god it was
it was a nightmare brought her to a
these this
amazing couple's house she i like the
door i left through
she this beautiful old spanish house and
this door from the 20s
she bit through the entire door her face
was covered in blood like her teeth were
like you wanted to get to you
she jumped a fence she was it was just
like yeah they call you and say like
like four in the morning they were like
you have to come get her like she's
she's gonna hurt they're like we think
she's gonna hurt herself trying to find
you
so it was like this whole process of
like detachment you know i had this dog
that was like
it was part chihuahua that i fostered
and his name was charlie he's so cute
and he um he had like the craziest
high-pitched
scream you've ever heard in your entire
life and every time i'd take him to
somebody like someone would fill out an
application
and i'd go to their house for them to
just meet him he the second they touched
him or tried to lift him he'd let out
the it was like
it was like a woman like screaming at
the top of her lungs
and the person would immediately like
like drop him really put him down
because it was so frightening
and then finally like the fourth or
fifth person that i met with he did
it and she was like oh that's hilarious
like she just didn't care and she was
like
oh like i i think she said she like had
a dog when she was little that did that
when it got scared and she was like
oh like i love him and she like didn't
care and i kept thinking the whole time
like i'm not gonna find anybody that is
gonna understand like get to know the
dog well enough to realize what a great
dog it is because he just wouldn't stop
screaming
but um but anyway so it turned out
really well because she ended up like
adopting him and they were kind of
they're like the perfect fit and now i
still get to see him sometimes so
it ended up oh i have visitation rights
on all my fosters yeah it's the best
i can come any time um but that
you know full circle to what we're just
talking about in relationships like that
i think it's the same thing in
relationships like if you don't want to
hear a woman scream don't date me uh but
you might be
yeah i'm not for you
if i don't remind you of something in
your childhood you're probably not going
to want to be with me
you know it's interesting because um
when uh we started today my producer
showed up and was like miranda's on
i know her dad i go to her her dad's
child
dry cleaning business that's crazy and
he sounds so cool and so proud of you
and so available
your mom sounds so healthy and because
we recreate our childhood circumstances
essentially our whole life is just
either
recreating your childhood circumstances
subconsciously whether it was dramatic
healthy unhealthy whatever it was
it seems like you had a pretty healthy
thing and
whoever you date is gonna have to be
fucking healthy hopefully maybe i'll
find
the right person i think it just you
know
like takes a while to find the perfect
person for you maybe or
i guess it's kind of weird like if you
only date like if you only have dated
like one person in your entire life i
feel like it would be hard
to like you know know what you want yeah
so maybe it's a good thing that it's
like a lot of bad dates yeah no you have
to
look at it that way you have to have go
on a lot of dates
to know what you don't want and you have
to have something to compare it to so if
the perfect person comes along and you
have nothing to compare it to
how are you going to know yeah because
like i thought my high school boyfriend
was like perfect because he was the
first person i ever like that's rated
yeah
yeah when you have no frame of reference
everybody's
everyone's perfect pretty good so go on
as many horrible dates as you possibly
can
so when i you know it's so funny people
always say like when um
they try to set me up with people
they're like oh this guy's kind of a
womanizer he's like dated a lot of women
i'm like good
that's perfect like number one i want
someone who's gotten a lot out of their
system
and has a lot to compare me to because
if when someone's like oh he's been an
eight-year relationship i'm like no
thanks
no no no no no no i would like him to go
date like 50 people for six months and
then date me
so there's some form of reference that's
smart too because most people that are
getting out of like an eight-year
relationship probably aren't going to
want to get in another relationship
really quick yeah and then you're gonna
i don't know be one of the random people
though yeah i'm just like i'm just like
i don't want to be compared to one
person
i want to be compared to like 50 people
you want to know you're better than 50.
not one person yeah like i don't think i
get that impressive if you're with
someone for eight years i just don't
feel like i can follow that like date a
bunch of messes
and then come to me and comparatively
i'm gonna look awesome
you know like i it's taken me a long
time uh
to do i'm trying to think of other
things like what what are you is there
anything in your
life that you're like lost about and
i'll try to fix it then i'm lost about
other than the dating thing
um i'm trying to think of something else
to do like as a career
i think of like something that i'm like
super passionate about like and i'm
having trouble with that
really yeah like i don't know i think
it'd be really nice to have like
you should definitely have a skincare
line because of your freaking
face what do you do to your what is what
do you think this is so broken out what
do you put on it uh
i feel like ever since the quarantine
started like um people's faces are
breaking out
well mine is right i have the mask acne
i get acne from wearing a mask
but that's nice because you can and then
well it's like it's like
it's a vicious cycle it's like i have
acne because i wear a mask and then i
wear the mask to cover the acne so it's
just like a
vicious cycle yeah like you just can't
like what do you put on your skin
um i've been using you put a lot of
stuff on here
yes i do i follow it a lot like your
face is so
shiny and nice i've been putting oil on
my face i kind of feel like i started
using oil because i saw like how shiny
your face was but um and you're like
that i started breaking out
this is your fault oh yeah maybe but um
but yeah i've been putting like oil on
my face for the first time and i love it
like with a little dropper thingy and
then you
it looks incredible it's your skin is
amazing is this
because of me i think it i can i take
credit for it
like because every time you post on your
story like you're perfect glowing
skin it reminds me to go put some on i'm
like super lazy with my
my skin too like i'll like go hike and
then i won't wash my face right after
and i think that's
like you're an animal yeah you're a
monster
how could you let me in your house you
and your dirty face and your seven cats
this is not the miranda i thought i was
gonna meet today
my seven cats am i edgy yet is that your
little
little edge what else must i do
okay so you wake up in the morning and
you put
well you wait well you go to bed at 5
a.m i wake up you're wild i am
edgy right i thought i was walking in
people don't think i am but i've got a
little something right she's
wild she goes to bed at five in the
morning she wakes up at two
do i have 30 animals yeah goes for a
hike
doesn't
goes out with a guy with zebra pants
goes on a bad day tonight
a guy sets himself on fire and kills
himself doesn't even cry about it
yeah what do you need a
you're wild thanks
thank you watch his whitney coming
stories
oh yeah that like that right there
you're fucking punk rock dude
now if i just dye my hair and i do a
couple other
i cuss a little your mom picks out your
your mom i actually do cuss a little do
you also what's your favorite curse word
probably fuck
fuck is such a great word so good like
when you say it it really gets the
message
it's like i actually don't say it a lot
because i love it's like i don't drink
you don't overuse it
i purposely deprive myself of things so
when i do use them
i get the maximum dopamine so i don't
drink like coca-cola a lot
on purpose so when i do i'm like oh god
it's good
yeah and when she does she does when i
drink it
are you okay yeah i like to i like to
deprive myself so i can really get the
full effect and that's how i am with the
word fuck too
i don't say it a ton so that when i
could say it it's like feel like when
you stub your toe that's just like
fuck like instantly makes your toe feel
better
and everybody like pays attention to
when you say that word people really
listen when you especially you
if you said fuck i'd be like yeah you
should rebrand yourself like a new song
like taylor did you just come right out
the gate
a song called fuck yeah like damn
what do you get angry party bee's new
song i do but only at my mom
like i can't imagine what makes you she
like makes you frustrated
yeah like we like more than anyone for
some reason my mom and i like
well my favorite quote is um your mom
knows how to push your buttons because
she installed them
oh my god she knows exactly where your
buttons are
she does know it is amazing how
moms can unleash a level of rage
you didn't know you had i know and it's
crazy how like you feel like they take a
bullet for you
but then they're also like your biggest
problem like they're driving you crazy
but they
are also like willing to put their life
on the line yeah it's like the most
confusing
relationship it's a kind of love what
did i say i think it was in my
second stand-up special where i said uh
my definition of love is being
willing to die for someone that you
yourself want to kill
like that's that's very much like a
mother that's a maternal love
and there's something weird i was with
my mom the other day she had coveted or
tested for positive for covid but you
know
it was like very scary and she's tested
negative sense and we were together and
it was just like you saw me with her
yeah did she get better fast
she uh she never showed symptoms thank
god but she's in a nursing home which
was super scary
when i'm with my mom i just can't stop
cleaning
it was wow so it's like you're coping
with having to be around
cause it's like leaning i just it's the
only time we get along
is when i'm just cleaning something or
being helpful
oh it's the only way that we're not
gonna fight yeah whitney was picking up
leaves out of the yard with her hands
like this
my mom hates it when i sit down like if
i'm sitting down and not doing anything
she'll be like what are you doing like
are you doing something today like are
you like she always wants me to be like
up doing something
for some reason i mean honestly
so i get the cleaning thing your mom i
mean like you're moving you're doing she
she raised a star so whatever your mom's
doing i
i would like to hire her to be my
manager frankly whatever your mom's
doing worked
so she would love to manage yeah she's
the one who's like come on we're going
to that audition and you were like no
she's like yeah we're going we're going
we're going to get you a house
a house yeah we're going to get you your
own house i mean i i respect the hustle
that's true there was some hustle there
i uh
yeah i get very activated around my mom
in a way that i i can't really
um that only she brings it only she
brings it out and only she can it's
interesting because
we talk about this a lot on this podcast
and just i think in general it's very
zeitgeisty to talk about trolls and
feedback and loving yourself and like
who can hurt you and like comment
section youtube comment section
instagram comment section the shit
people said nothing really scathes me
like i feel like i've been through a lot
of shit storms and had a lot of
different things come at me good bad
whatever
um the only person that can really hurt
my feelings is my mom
honestly i feel like that too i really
do and it's and it's
it's steep and it's your mom and it's as
simple as like
shit like she'll say something where
she'll be like uh she's like oh you're
wearing lip gloss and i'm like yeah
and she's like oh okay and i'm like what
they're thinking all day
all day all day what did that mean what
did she mean by that what do you mean am
i wearing a lip of course
was it what lip gloss was that and i
will just spin like she said to me once
um
i'm still talking about it this was like
three years ago i walked in to her
nursing home and she just went
you look healthy that's nice right
that's what and then i was like wait
what does that mean did i not look
healthy before have i never looked
healthy is this the first time i've
looked healthy what does that doesn't
mean i've gained weight
what does she say like it just i'll
obsess about it
it's like a little um it's like a
backhanded compliment
i totally get that like i'll leave the
house and my mom will be like are you
wearing those pants
and i'll be like yeah like like why and
she'll i mean yes they're on me nothing
like i just i didn't know you still had
them
and i'll be like what and then of course
the rest of the time you're wearing the
pants you're thinking like what was
wrong with the pants why did she bring
are you negging me
she might not even really be doing it on
purpose it's just like totally
it's just a thing it's like she's
probably not on purpose there's
i haven't i don't think our moms have
any idea how much they hurt yeah because
my mom would i don't think they want to
it's scary to have a child too like
imagine like if you have a child
by accident you're not even doing it on
purpose you're just shattering them
every time you ask them a question
you're ruining their life
that's a lot of pressure imagine your
mom's like yeah i just asked you what
pants you're wearing like why are you
collapsing
into a ball my mom does this thing where
she'll say sorry to me
to like win something like she'll go
like i'll be like oh
i like your shirt oh sorry i didn't mean
to ask you about it sorry sorry that i
did that
sorry oh like she's already she's like
okay i'm not mad at you she's like sorry
sorry well that's that is pointed
like that's actually that is intense and
i'll be like i'm at work sorry i'm so
sorry
well that is i do think a lot our moms
did not have
the tools we have so i say this with
forgiving all of
oh yeah my mom's great all the women
before us that
that generation did not have a lot of
tools their moms did not have tools
their dads were in wars and had no
emotional bandwidth then their moms
couldn't vote so let's just be real
patient with all of our moms
but i i do know that in my the women in
my family systems
on both sides guilt was a big there was
just this
ancestral guilt everything was run by
guilt
and everything there's and there's a lot
of indirect passive aggressive
communication that they inherited it was
a lot of like well sorry sorry
you know and it was a lot of like oh
you're not gonna come okay fine
it was a lot of that yeah instead of
there was no like i want you to come
with me
will you you oh you're not gonna come
well that hurt my feelings there was not
that direct communication you couldn't
admit you needed help you couldn't admit
you had to like get it in some secret
like
you couldn't talk about your feelings
because women already had too many
feelings and no one wanted to fucking
hear about them
so you just had to sneak your feelings
in yeah that's so true
yeah it was a lot of like my mom wasn't
supposed to have kids either so like
she's so
do you mean your mom wasn't supposed to
look like they said you you're not ever
going to have that that's why i think
she was good
some do with her vagina um so
she's like so terrified of something
happening to me that she'll ruin things
so that i never do them and it like
sticks with me forever like
like i like i went to the theme park for
the first time big deal left my small
town
a theme park universal city otherwise
universal studios oh wow i was so
thrilled about it and the entire trip
she would call me back
i saw a kid they got their legs cut off
on a roller coaster she's like uh you
know people drown in the ocean every day
so you can never enjoy she's like
i have such a fear of everything because
my mom is like so terrified of something
happening to me that she'll just ruin it
i'm so terrified of something i get it
too i'm terrified of something happening
we had the biggest fighter before i went
to college
she was like well you know all these
things happened in college like was
wanting me to go to college but was
fully trying to ruin it so that i didn't
do anything
you know what i said what i'm hearing
are two things
number one a mother's guilt of like i'm
just gonna
prepare you for all the horrible things
because i have no control
imagine the fear i mean it must be
really scary i know i'm gonna have
i'm sure i'm gonna have kids even if i
hire someone else to do it
i know i'm gonna probably have kids at
some point but
the fear i have of just my dogs
like i mean the other dog getting hurt
yeah i think yeah
like i think that when you've had bad
things happen
you assume the worst thing is gonna
happen at every moment like every time i
throw the ball for my dog into the pool
i'm like my brain goes the ball is gonna
have a hole in it and it's gonna sink to
the bottom and then he's going to try to
get it and he's going to drown
like that that to me is a perfectly
normal thought like i just that the
worst possible thing that could happen
is going to happen
that's how like mom's brains are working
that's how mom's brains work all
of the time my mom's like my best friend
but my mom's also like a little crazy
yeah
i love it everyone's mom is so it's like
as we say in elena if it's not one thing
it's your mother
uh and they have i mean imagine imagine
loving something so much
and i mean i i disagree the fact that
your mom even let you come here today
means she is very casual like i i don't
think i would let my kid leave the house
i don't i would be able to handle it my
mom fell off a ladder once like um
not too long ago like a couple years ago
she wanted to get the christmas lights
down on a day my dad was that is how i'm
gonna die by the way trying to take down
the christmas lights
and my dad said like oh i'll take him
down but he was working so my mom was
like i'm not waiting so she went
i'm your mom she was like i'm not doing
that like she was like i need these
lights down like this is embarrassing
like people in the neighborhood are
judging it's like
the next day after christmas love your
mom so she got a ladder out and she
started taking him down
and a dog came up like a random stray
dog they live on like a culver sack and
a random dog came up and i was like
i'm gonna go to petco and buy food like
see ya and i left my mom
taking down the christmas lights by
herself big mistake and then i got a
call
i was at petco from like a cross street
neighbor saying like there's an
ambulance here and your mom fell off the
ladder
and i was like what so i immediately
like obviously dropped everything i ran
i got i was pretty close but i got back
home like in five minutes and then
that's the difference between you i
would have finished the transaction
gotten the
food you're like i still don't hold on i
just need to get a little more food
but so then i i ran home and i got there
she was the all the paramedics were
around like the ambulance
she's laying in the front yard her bone
was completely
out of her leg like her bone was just
like hanging there like
outside of her leg and she was like how
bad is it and i was like it's not like
it's good it's not that bad and she
pushed it back in
she took her hand and like a piece of
her sock was stuck to it and it ripped
off and it went inside
like a little piece of her sock because
she pushed it went into her body and it
was a big deal later trying to remove
the piece of the sock from her bone that
she shoved back into her leg
and then i took her she had to go to
like the closest like place
because it was an emergency and she kept
saying in the waiting room you should
have taken me to cedars you don't really
love me
and i was like mom i was like it's i was
like an ambulance like
i had to like i don't decide where you
go like and she was she was freaking out
and then they had to do like an
emergency like surgery on her leg and
then
right before they took her in i always
tell people this like my friends and
stuff because it's like so our
relationship
but she said to me in front of like the
nurses and everyone because they said
like say goodbye to your mom because
like they're we're gonna put her under
like for the surgery
and i was like okay like it's gonna be
fine like like see after the surgery and
she was like
i don't want you to feel bad for all the
bad things that you've done to me
and i was like she was like if i don't
wake up
she was like don't feel bad i just don't
want you to like live with that
and i was like what so then the entire
time she was in the surgery i was like
thinking about it she said that
and i swear when she woke up and i
brought it up she was like i don't she
was like i don't even remember saying
that
and she was like if i did say that i'm
in a nice way because i really don't
want you to live with any guilt dude
it's like
uh like i'm sorry you mean i became a
famous star
i'm the perfect child i that is like mom
mom like mom every time i get a fight
she looks like i'm such a terrible
mother
oh my mom 100 real quick whenever i
would have something
happen to music and i'd be like well
maybe i'll get hit by a bus maybe i'll
get hit by a bus tomorrow like and
you'll get your way yeah maybe i'll get
hit by a bus it's like well no i'm kind
of just hungry like i don't what is this
bus this month
i um they are that should be your online
dating profile moms moms are great
benton that's a hot take
but i my mom uh in uh i'm in a 12-step
program and allanon
and you do a uh step that's called
amends
where you like if anyone's ever gotten a
random apology from someone who's
getting sober or whatever that's an
amends
right so it's uh you write down all the
people that you've harmed and then you
make an amends to them if it doesn't
harm them or others right so
so uh i'm not an aaa but i'm an elenant
and uh
the heart it's interesting because an
allen on what they say is um
on this step you start and you're like i
don't know anyone apology people owe me
an apology you know like that's sort of
like
sort of alan 101 and usually they say
all the people you think
owe an apology to you or probably who
you own apology to and it's interesting
to go through something oh yeah that's
right and you're usually instead of
apologizing for things that
you know uh addicts in their addiction
did like you know crashing cars or
stealing money that's usually what like
people in aa or
or na will apologize for and alan on
it's usually like i'm sorry that i
was so controlling i'm sorry that i uh
was manipulative i'm sorry that i had
such high expectations which is such a
passive aggressive thing to say
um you couldn't meet me i'm sorry that i
had such high expectations and you
couldn't meet them like it's
al-anon amends are very tricky because
they can come off very judgmental
like i'm sorry i was so micromanaging of
your mess you know like i'm sorry that i
kept trying to fix you
literally i'm trying i'm sorry i didn't
just let you stay broken
um you know so it's like really hard to
do these amends
but i realized that i owed my mom some
events
um because uh you know we have so much
addiction in my family and
from what she comes from i i had anger
come out after and i
had i wanted to apologize for a couple
times that i released my anger at her
cause sometimes we
get the angers the people we love the
most which makes no sense because we
know they won't leave us i guess or
whatever you know so i'm the nicest to
the people that are the meanest to me
and the meanest the people that deny
this to me it's taking me a long time to
look at that and so um and so a couple
times she was moving nursing homes and
she had a stroke and i was just so angry
at the situation and sometimes i would
take it out on her
you know and i would just be like i just
got you a new wheelchair i can't get
another wheelchair we just got like
i think we were both trying to like cope
with the situation so
i i go to make my amends and i say i'm
sorry about this time i lost my temper
i'm sorry but this time i lost my temper
and then i went back
then and it was great and we cried and
all the stuff and then very powerful
step and very therapeutic and
truly for the next like couple years
every time i go back she's like you know
what else you forgot to apologize for
oh my god i was like no no this isn't
this isn't homemade not like a
free-for-all like
no no you know she'd be like remember
that time used to complain about when i
would drive you to school and i'm like
mom no no
you don't like she was like i really
liked that day when we did that yeah
i was like can we do that again i was
like this isn't an
ongoing thing i wasn't sorry about that
yeah no i i don't apologize for that
uh it's just like you just really
enjoyed it i know and it's funny because
we we used to get fights all the time
and she'd be like well i drove you to
school every day and i used to make you
lunch and i'd be like that's
i think that's just called parenting you
had a child i was thinking you're the
one that decided to have me like when
you sort of i don't think i owe you for
that
you must start to feel like that at some
point for like parents like you're doing
so much for somebody else like you're
probably just like after a while like
why do i owe this
i do think parents at like 35 should be
able to just like invoice their kids
just like you owe me you owe me like
eighty thousand dollars
in lunchables you know do you think
you're gonna get married
um i want to someday the person who's
saying they were gonna get married after
a third date
but that's like a programming thing i
think they're i don't
you know i think we're programmed to
think that way and i think i think
that's okay like i used to vaseline on
it and be like oh that's so unhealthy
like
after a third date i'm like this is my
husband but like
why not have a i like that because you
can have like a high bar for somebody
is this guy husband material is this guy
father material
would you actually like want to hang out
with this person yes yes you know like i
think if you
put that on to someone even though it
feels a little bit like
boy crazy or something like it's been
stigmatized or pathologized to think
that way but i think you should be like
this is my husband if not then fucking
you're out otherwise i'll hang out with
my girlfriends and
work on myself so i just should just
make my thing like looking for a husband
literally just be like husband dude that
is such a fucking power move
what is this thing where girls like
we're all out there dating pretending
we're not looking for husbands like i'm
just the cool girl and i eat wings and
like i don't want anything serious like
get the fuck out of here
we're all looking for husbands i mean
well maybe
i actually might be the operation but at
this current moment but
i do think that it's like the idea of
like are you the father of my kids
on a first date absolutely that doesn't
mean i wanna have your kid tomorrow i'm
not trying to like secretly like
i'm not gonna steal your sperm out of a
condom in the trash can i'm not a
psychopath
but like i do think that that's a fair
um like bard set like to try to figure
out like
that's fair that should be your tinder
bottle the only thing i don't have is a
husband
[Laughter]
what can you bring to the table that's
my thing what can you bring to the table
that i don't
don't already have like i've worked so
fucking hard
you have worked so fucking hard to get
everything that you have like
i s you certainly have to bring
something to the table i know what i
bring to the table
right you show up like i'm an icon
legend a star now what now what
now what can you take good instagram
photos
can you put a phone on a tripod can you
shoot good slow-mo videos
i mean it's i i don't i don't understand
why that's
an unfair expectation i like it go all
around like some days i'm like oh well i
wanted to get married and then other
days i'm like
i don't need to get married like maybe
i'll never get married i don't know it's
kind of i do that too and i go
you know what i do need to get married
if it's the right person
it makes sense for tax purposes and i
don't if it's the wrong person
and i'm also being on i was thinking
about this yesterday when i was thinking
about you
bike riding uh i was thinking that
i believe that a five-year marriage is a
success
five years ten years a long time that's
a long-ass time
marriage was invented when the life
expectancy was like
28. i wonder what the average amount of
time is like
that people stay together but they know
they're like gonna get a divorce like i
wonder if it's like just the last year
of the five years
that's such a good question i don't i
feel like once you're married like you
probably would
stick with it for quite a while to try
to make it work yeah yeah totally yeah
you're just like oh god we're still
paying off the
flowers at this point you'd even like
put something you just got a new washer
and dryer
you put so much into it yeah i feel
another year i feel like
there'd be more divorces if weddings
were less expensive you know what i mean
i feel my friend just eloped and got
married by elvis and vegas a few months
ago
that's kind of before the pandemic yeah
like like a little bit before it started
it was like kind of
on the verge i'm obsessed with you but i
have to pee
do you have to pee um actually yes okay
let's pee we're gonna take a pee break
and we're coming back what's the show
called that my dad loves it's where's
the
it has okay funny so
he literally watches it religiously so
miranda's dad
tom is a big celebrity in these parts
and he knows me from a show called
bring the funny weird funny you should
ask funny you should ask yeah
yeah funny you should ask he watches
that every single day at work
and he says that his favorite episodes
are the ones with you
and you wanted me to ask you some
questions
if you're prepared i'm like turning the
tables on i'm okay so miranda's now
hosting the show
channeling her dad what what are your
questions
tom what are your questions so he wanted
to know if you come up with the jokes
beforehand or if you come up with him on
the spot
jokes here no the jokes on that show oh
i was like god i hope these are on the
spot
um if i was i was scripting all this i
should really find a new career
they were really funny and he wanted to
know if it was possible for people to
come up with stuff like that off the top
of their heads that's a
show where it's like uh uh i think we
write the jokes ahead of time on
that show okay yeah should i lie to him
for sure i'm sorry
i'm really gonna disappoint your dad um
sometimes i'll like improvise
stuff but for the most part i think you
have like a heads up
yeah like we know what the question is
and have time to like write a joke yeah
lie to him i don't want to ruin his
his best moments
but we do improvise sometimes okay i'll
definitely let him know
is he a big comedy fan um not really and
he also doesn't find like
basically anyone funny like he it's so
hard to get him to like like a song or
think something's funny like he's the
hardest like critic on earth so it's a
huge
compliment to you that my dad tom
cosgrove
thinks you're amazing that's my demo
tough dads dads
hard to please dads honestly i was
raised by one
i've spent my whole life trying to get
dad's approval including my own
never got it so i'm glad at least i got
someone's father's approval because i
still don't have it
you do i'm just kidding does he tell you
he's proud of you to you
oh yeah oh good good because i have this
theory that a lot of parents
they and people in general they talk
shit to our face
and nice behind our backs you know and
something that
actually really oh i'm gonna cry what if
i cry i'm gonna try not to
um when my dad passed i met a lot of his
friends
and oh
when i met a lot of my dad's friends he
said
i'm all he ever talked about how proud
he was of me but he never told me that
so it took other can you imagine
now cry about you're the guy that killed
himself no we could do it together we
could
be twins he's like really nice and
crying against me more sad than my dad
like when i think
about my dad like sticking up for me or
me too like that nothing gets any more
than that that's like 100 saddest things
my dad texts me every day and tells me
he's proud of me and i was like haven't
done anything but thanks
what yes he got me every day that makes
me so happy i think sometimes our
oh my god i'm crying and i just really
like all i did was get groceries today
but like thanks
i know but like you are you and you've
become you and you grew up where you
grew up and overcame
so much adversity and i mean dads
dads man that's how they don't they
don't always show love
in the way that we see what you're
looking for but they're doing it
it's never the kind of love you want
like i kind of just want a necklace
but i think about my dad and like how
you know
his dad was in a war and was emotionally
very shut down and wasn't
you know there was not a lot of like
physical love shown there was not a lot
of like
verbal like my dad i remember he never
hugged me
but at uh basketball game once where i
did a very good job because i'm very
athletic
uh he put his arm around me like he
tried to hug me like from the side it
was just like this really weird there's
this picture of us having our first
weird like
awkward hug yeah like this side hug like
we never really looked at each other
like it's just kind of like
it's um not so sad to imagine someone
like wanting to like
he probably wanted to do a full hug but
it was like uncomfortable it's exactly
right and i think that i
um i think a big part of why i gravitate
oh god i'm going to cry more uh so much
to animals and especially abused animals
is because especially
you know dogs i don't know as much about
cats but horses and dogs when they've
been abused like
they want so badly to connect with you
and love you
and they want to know like something
good's out there yes but they also their
body has been trained to be scared so
you see this like
push-pull of something that wants so
badly to connect but is still scared and
protecting itself and just has this
habit
you know like when i first got daisy she
wouldn't let me touch her
and she would like move towards me and
then her body would and i could see in
her eyes that she wanted so badly to
trust me but just
didn't i'm sure didn't have the proof
yet you know like just didn't have the
um it didn't uh feel safe yet and i and
that's
a feeling that i felt with my dad a lot
where he's like i want to be able to be
a better dad and love you more and
connect with you more is just like
didn't know how it just like didn't have
the tools well it's kind of like what
you said about moms like
dads do the the best they can do too
with what they got
yeah and i always i'm always really
proud of my parents because they're
really good about trying to do better
than their parents
they're really conscious that's that's
that's a success if you can do
an inch better than the people that came
before you
so we're like um it's an interesting
theme of this podcast like i still
find myself at 37 years old when i see
her just regressing
like remember when i was cleaning her
wheelchair
yeah outside while the nurse was there
and you were like still cleaning it the
nurse was like it's fine
i was the nurse was mean no it doesn't
mean she was just like
yeah when you have different levels of
clean yeah but i just was like
obsessively like trying to make
everything
perfect perfect you know and trying to
be useful to her
and try and uh trying to
make her proud or you know whatever
she's having a great time by the way i
thought
and i was ruining it by pointing out a
plain balloon yeah
what is balloon ball you mean like a
beach ball like you throw it up in the
air and then when it comes near you
like like in a concert like in the mosh
pit of a concert when you like hit balls
around pretty much yes
that is what it is you've never played
balloon ball no
when i was a little kid my parents
called me mitts magursky
and i would hit a balloon ball and
they'd cheer for me
it was like a thing when i was like six
or seven and now then they did it to my
grandma
what scares you fires are scary yeah
fire's scarier that's definitely a good
one car accidents i got in a really bad
car accident and i
broke my um my ankle like four or five
years ago
really yeah and i got all this metal in
my angle and stuff what
you have can you go through a metal
detector well i got the metal removed
now
but you know it's funny it actually made
me really nervous about airports because
when i had the metal in they kept they
gave me like a doctor's note and kept
saying like
you're going to set it off and i never
did so maybe the metal detectors aren't
no
airports aren't as good as yeah as you
might think but
i was on like a i was on a tour bus and
i got in like a car accident like i was
sleeping on the back of the tour bus
and the driver fell asleep and we got in
like a really bad accident and when i
woke up i was just like sitting i feel
like i remember this this was like a big
news story
it was weird i don't know if like a lot
of people knew but it was just like
it was just like a crazy weird thing
that happened so now i'm i'm kind of
scared to get in a car accident
like that would be like a big fear of
mine i don't know
because it's like creepy to be
especially if you're sleeping in a car
like for a while after it happened i
would like wake up
in the night because i like remember
because i heard like a big um
sound when the tour bus ran into another
car there was like a semi-truck in the
middle of the road
you should write a book why have you not
done that just write a book
but it was crazy and my mom was with me
and actually we
we were for some reason i usually slept
and you know like those bullet things on
tour buses yeah like
i usually slept in those and my mom
would sleep in the room like the back
actual bedroom because
um because i like like hanging out with
everybody and i wanted to like
be like where everybody was and you're
so abusive to her that's the least you
can do
i i actually had uggs on like ugg shoes
and i went into the back room where my
mom was and i was like on the computer
and normally i would have fallen asleep
like in the other area but i just for
some reason fell asleep there
and i guess the uggs like helped me a
lot i sound like i'm like
endorsing uggs i'm not but they like
saved your ankle they like helped my
ankle a lot because i don't know if you
know this but the bottom of uggs are
like rubber and they're really thick
yeah
and apparently it like stopped my whole
leg from breaking it like made only my
ankle break
because i i like flew out of the bed and
i hit the wall so my foot like
hit the wall and the uggs protected it
so and then a bunch of people had to cut
the ugg off like with
giant scissors it was crazy what a hero
yeah oh and also like there was a um
some kind of like bookcase in the back
room and when we got in the accident the
bookcase fell on top of me
and when i woke up i was so disoriented
i threw the bookcase like
off of my body and it landed on top i
heard oh
oh and i was like mom
and then my mom had a concussion okay
that's what your mom was talking about
your mommy my mom does have yeah yeah
yeah yeah little girl i get it like your
mom
right when she was on going under
anesthesia remembered you throwing a
bookcase out probably yeah yeah
that might have come into play or wild
edgy i told you you know it's
interesting i feel like i
i had so much um
what that is such a weird story like
you've had a crazy life
it was really weird i had these like
assumptions that your life has just been
like
this fairy tale not that it has just
you've had some there's been some
wild shit has happened to you my mom
didn't know that i did that like she
didn't know
for like a solid three hours but it was
you yeah like she kept she thought that
it was from hitting her head on the wall
because she hit her head
you should have just gone with that
story well i thought like well like
until she wakes up i'm not gonna
like i'm not gonna tell like exactly
what happened did anyone else get hurt
on the bus except you two
um the driver did yeah his like arms
were severed
it was good why am i telling you when
you're told
[Laughter]
this is why you we get along as you use
humor as a coping mechanism that's true
because you your life has been a
nightmare
uh it's been a night your life is
walking if there's one take away from
his interview
your life isn't an absolute nightmare
your life
constant horror movie no that is the
most horror movie
that's how every horror movie starts
like a balloon ball
like inside a nursing home like
that's like pennywise like through the
balloon down the street
like i think you have obviously a very
resilient triumphant
humor mechanism getting you through all
this i love that you love this right my
ankle was broken
his arms were severed but my ankle was
closed i'm like well let's get back to
my ankle
and i love uggs but he doesn't have arms
he doesn't have arms they reattached his
arms actually
you've been through some shit there was
one good part to it there was like a
really cute firefighter
that came onto the i told you what did i
say you need to be with a firefighter
that was my chance i was in effingham
where is he of effingham illinois here's
the firefighter shout out
what did he do do you remember him he
just he carried me to the um
ambulance what when was this
it was like five six years ago he's
probably married and very happy
okay well but just in case you can't
wreck a happy home
so if you're listening dm benton
and we'll we'll put you in touch it was
like out of a movie there were like
explosions in the background and he was
like carrying me and running it caught
on fire
moment yeah it's like waiting to exhale
when she's walking away from the car
wow it was exciting
you have been through a lot all in
effingham
what's your typical day what's tomorrow
um honestly i'll probably go to sleep at
five in the morning watching netflix
yeah and then i will get up at like one
take care of the animals
yeah my small farm yeah um go hiking
yeah
nothing exciting figure out what you
want to do with your life yeah now that
you've caught you've already conquered
two businesses and you're like no what
should i do
come up with a hobby work on your skin
line
i don't know what does one do after they
escape death that many times
i know i have escaped death many times
yeah great
your cats are rubbing off on you that's
true
how many night is it nine lives nine
lives i think so i don't know i i
truly know nothing about cats and it's
starting to be intentional with this you
seem like you'd know something about
cats
i i don't not like i do like cats
like i don't like like the the movie
especially
um but i i just don't i'm so codependent
and i'm so
needy with animals and cats
are repelled by that and i just i can't
i don't have good chemistry with cats
i guess i'm like that too like even
though i have cats like they're they're
just nothing like dogs like they just
don't
like thank you for saying that i cuz i
hate it when people go like
my cat's like a dog like no it's not
maybe they got lucky they got like the
one cat that's like i'm like
yeah your dog hey first of all your cat
hates you uh i'm just telling you that
right now
um but i just i don't know how to attune
to them i don't know what they value and
i don't know how to make them need me
i think they're like kind of evil deep
down
[Laughter]
and their saliva is full of toxins
really yeah
that's what they look like that's why
they like their claws to like coat it in
it
yeah they say if a cat buys you you
should go to the er
like right away because the amount of
bacteria but i just i don't i think
they're so beautiful
i'm fascinated by them i do lots of like
work in uh rescue with like lions and
tigers and i love looking i'm
fascinated by them but i just i don't
totally
know how to have them around all the
time without spiraling
uh and feeling bad about myself
cats make you feel bad about you like i
just i'm like why don't you like me like
it just kicks up stuff right dogs are
like confidence boosters dogs are just
like oh great yes they're obsessed with
you all the time like i'm just very
needy when it comes to my animals i'm
very smothering and i need an animal
that is okay with being smothered
i just don't like that cats bite like
they randomly will bite you for no
reason like you could be petting them
things are going great and then all of a
sudden they attack you and when they
paw you like as if they're you know what
they do with the cat or whatever but i'm
like do you just think
i'm a couch do you value me the same as
a chair
like you have no respect for me like the
way that they do that like you're
sharpening your claws on my skin
like you have making me bleed you have
no respect for me
like like i am just i'm nothing to you
yeah so
i just i have four cats and i'm
completely on board yeah and i i've
tried to rescue cats before
i rescued one uh in studio city where i
used to live and i
find this cat outside i bring it inside
i have for like three days i'm like
feeding it
i'm like trying to kind of just take
care of it uh i put it on social media
to be like i found this you know
straight cat i'm gonna find it at home
like 20 minutes later my neighbor came
over and was like excuse me did you just
put my cat on instagram
i was like i'm so sorry i was like is
this your cat and she was like yeah i
was like well why was it outside and
she's like cats go outside and i was
like
what they do like i just kidnapped her
cat
thank you she's like she's like i
thought it was dead and i was like why
why
it would have been if i hadn't rescued
it like it's like very weird thing and i
actually put my cat on instagram
yeah it has 18 000 followers it's
verified i was like i have found a lot
of homes for your cat that i think might
be better
and so that was a little bit of a
kerfuffle because i don't understand
where they live
i know i don't like that they just
wander i think that i i think
they can live outside but with coyotes
out here maybe they're indoor i don't
know i thought cats only lived inside
so i got confused and then the other
time i found a cat um
was at like two in the morning i was
driving home from doing stand-up and i
see this cat in the road
and like a cartoon i drive
past and i see a coyote and then i drive
like 10 more feet and i see a cat
like like out of a fucking runner
like cartoon looney tunes i see a
fucking coyote like looking at a cat and
i'm like
so i get out of my car i pick up the cat
it's one of those really long haired
ones
i put it inside i put it on my dashboard
it starts shitting on my dashboard i
take
it to the vet it's like an older looking
cat i think i bring it in
they call for the chip and the owner is
like it's trying to die
when cats get older they leave and they
try to die
and she's like this cat has left every
night for the past two weeks and people
keep bringing it to them
they won't let it die it's costing me
all this money
in vet bills because nobody will just
let it die trying to die
i'm trying to die and because fucking
l.a like no one will just let anime
yeah so like literally she was just like
okay
and so i like brought it back to her
house and she's like all right here we
go
you're like do you want it yeah i'm like
if you want me to get that i never
found like it was just like everybody's
like what do you mean cats want to die
like what are you even talking about
they just go commit suicide i know i
don't know it's when they're old they
want to die
alone when they're they go hiding
somewhere it's time to die
come dive with me you will be alone
because i'm the perfect person to die in
here
yeah so i that to me always felt like i
just was like i don't understand these
things
how are you like i'm gonna die soon i'm
gonna just like go out in the road i
don't need nobody
i don't know it's just it seems a little
bit they come into this world alone
yeah they want to leave alone yeah and
the whole thing just felt it feels very
um
dark not like a dog yeah it's depressing
to me a big f you're the owner like you
took care of me this whole time and like
i gotta go
i gotta go i'm gonna go fucking die it's
like how do you know when you're gonna
die what if you were we weren't you
thought you were gonna die two weeks ago
and say your goodbyes now yeah and a
bunch of people rescued you and you're
still alive so what the fuck do you know
about death like and i thought animals
like live in the moment and that was a
good thing about them
yes and also you guys don't know about
antibiotics or vets
we do like you don't know when you're
gonna die yeah they do
except except squirrels apparently have
a concept of time because they bury food
and they know that they're they might
know that they've got this coming they
know they're gonna need food in the
future but they don't know death is
coming don't they also lose the food
most of the time like forget where they
put it
yes which sarah silverman has an amazing
joke about that
about how the reason trees are planted
are because squirrels forget where they
buried their acorns
which is like just the cutest thing ever
i know i love that
um have you had any fun i've had a great
time really thank you so much
is this so weird it's fun no it's not
weird actually i thought it was going to
be much more weird than it is
really yeah because i don't know i
thought i wouldn't have like anything to
talk about but
what do you mean i feel like we could do
this for five more hours well the fact
that you've sat beside
just a set of ears and haven't said
anything this whole time really
impressive oh wait i actually literally
didn't notice those this entire time
what are those
like she's so respectful she's not you
move it over so we can see it in the
camera
these are asmr ears oh we should do an
asmr video with
we haven't figured out how to work him
yet calm down oh wait so what do you
do you listen to asmr i know what that
is kind of like you talk really like
really
i don't know if i have a voice for that
kind of work can i tell you something
if you did asmr videos on youtube you
would have more money
than elon musk frankly what do people
talk about like while they do it you can
talk or just make noises
you can like mouth sounds or they'll put
like stuff in the ear and pull it out of
the ear
they like literally just do this they
like take a cap off a pen and put it
back on they like tear a piece of paper
they just like and people just love
hearing it helps them fall asleep
oh i didn't know that yeah it's like
what they fall asleep too benton i
thought it was like
like a sexual thing i didn't know that
sure there probably are some somewhere
i think that one was calming when i
watched
it i felt it was sexual because i i just
was like it was just like a lot of like
whispering and like
i don't i i feel like i maybe but
projected onto it a little bit but then
when it turned into
tearing paper and stuff it feels like
nails on a chalkboard to my ears so i
feel like for a musician it might be a
nightmare because like the sound is
really crisp is that the point
that's the idea you get a really really
good microphone and like whisper
and that one is i've never seen anything
like that yeah and that one's two ears
so like if you're on this side it sounds
like they're just in this here or vice
versa and isn't it
what is called audio meridian response
uh
a-s yeah audio sensory synthetic
sensory meridian response so there's
something about what it does to your
brain it sounds like for some people
they feel like tingles
oh like it like makes them actually like
feel good like literally
like the sound does i gotta check some
asmr asmr yeah
it's like people use it for like therapy
and stuff now like doctors is like
caught for anxiety things like that is
it like how people listen to like beach
sounds or like
yeah it's like that like that yeah but
different i guess yeah there's something
like soothing about it
um some people do the opposite of my
podcast
there's something calming and relaxing
about it how are you guys getting into
it is that why
you got well we thought it'd be funny to
do like we
i thought if i read whitney's text
message to me
in asmr oh i'll definitely be watching
that
you you benton is really on one can you
make one about the yellowjackets
you're really into that benton made me
laugh so hard yesterday
talking about yellowjackets whitney is
it creepy that i know
why because your story
is that as funny as i think it is it's
very funny like i ca is any of this
funny
i like the way you say the word yellow
jacket yeah that's how she said that she
yeah she said
down my yard and yellow jackets i'm like
like can you give us some feedback on
the
do i do too many stories instagram
stories bring more
are you sure i'm all throughout my day i
watch those stories please keep them
coming i feel like
it looks insane like i bring up sarah
silverman again she
responded one of my stories the other
day i was like do you watch these like
the idea that people i know are
like in my head they just go out to like
strangers
and not people i actually have to see
you'd probably never want to have a
reality show but i feel like it's proof
that you could hold one up
people completely if you i know david
spade the other day said that he's like
why don't you guys just do a reality
show like i would watch
i hate money i hate money because benden
says i like to leave money on the table
that's my deal that's my deal i like to
have as little money as possible
i don't want to forget who i am she
likes saying it where i came from
yeah i don't um uh i just i don't think
about stories for some reason i just i
think of them as just like
our i think it is like my photo album
like it's just us like texting a video
to each other and then people will
i'll be walking down the street and
people are like and i'm like how did you
know that
like i just i think because i've been in
quarantine for so long i don't i just
you put on a computer and it's like
feels like you're just like gone
you just think it's like sending an
email to like one person it's like
you're like oh no a lot of people saw
that i literally fell asleep the other
night to you
um looking at your different um like
screens on your
tv like i was into that
i was like down from the entire ride
just like you know that feels
like a invasion of friendship in the
middle of the day it was daytime and the
screensaver was on and we were trying to
have a meeting and she was going look at
this
look at this right here this is where
where where is this you think
this is this is where do you think this
is look jellyfish there's no jellyfish
in the middle of our meeting i was like
are we is this what we're doing i'm
my favorite show on tv are apple
screensavers they just
they do like draw slow-mo drone shots of
just like forests and glaciers and
and jellyfish and yellowjackets and all
sorts and i
sit there and i watch it and it makes me
think i'm stoned because i'm like
i don't really smoke weed i don't really
drink and i'm like is this what it feels
like to be stoned like there's something
hypnotic about it maybe that's what asmr
is to other people
mine is visual so into that i was like
wow i cannot
think about anything else i i'll watch
him for hours yeah because she kept
going
and this happens on all the apple tvs
right like my one upstairs is on all
this oh yeah i have those on my tv
it like made me have a new appreciation
they move so slow
i think it's something about the
velocity at which they move
it goes on for so long and so okay okay
i know we've been here for too long but
i don't give a shit
so i'm watching it and i'm like i then
get in this i think this is what
meditation is
because i'm in the present moment i'm
like is this ever going to end
like why is this going on so long and
then i start thinking about the people
that put them together and i'm like
who makes up these time frames like why
would it be like three minutes the most
and then as soon as i think it's never
gonna end it switches to another one i'm
like oh
it's like it's just can you figure out a
way to like switch them
i was trying to put a button on the
remote everybody told me there's a
button but i don't think i want to
i think i want to be a prisoner i want
to be on the screen savers time
i don't want to be on my time i want to
i want to surrender some more relaxing
yes i wouldn't such a whitney thing to
do don't doesn't watch movies doesn't
watch tv listen to music but just on
your couch like
fully blank staring at your tv no
pictures on the walls just
[Laughter]
my house because you deprived yourself
of all that stuff it's like what you
were talking about yes
that's it she's like i've never seen a
picture here's what i'll say the more
tv you watch it's like the less exciting
life gets
so i've done this thing where i'm it's
like it's like what i imagine porn is
like the more porn you watch the less
exciting sex is going to be right
i've had guys say they take months off
porn and then they have sex and they're
like sex is amazing it's like yeah
always was you just got desensitized i
stopped watching tv for like a month
and then i turned it on were you here
when there was like a special on about
yeah you kept asking me do you do you
watch this show do you have you ever
seen this show before i was like i've
seen friends can you believe
you dude take a month off watching tv
and then go back to it and it will blow
your mind
i was watching commercials and i was
like whoa
look at the geico gekko that's so cool
like i was like a kid in a candy shop
he's so different now before he didn't
want to be the get-go and now he doesn't
do that
damn i watched a show called the rookie
and i was like whoa
look at these car chases like i was like
my brain was exploding
i watched a special of katie couric
interviewing regis philbin and i was
dying laughing that's how i knew i was
meant to be funny it wasn't
i don't think so i was just like so you
have to deprive yourself
i think in order to really enjoy
something so what i'll do before
podcasts
is i won't talk to anyone the day before
so that when i get in here i'm like so
excited to talk
you know what i mean whereas like i've
made the mistake before of
like having a bunch of meetings and then
podcasting and being like oh god i have
no brain power left like you have to
like
sort of put yourself in a situation
where you like you know need something
so it's kind of like when people are in
jail when they put them like in a room
away yeah
it's like very much how she lives oh
that's totally didn't you do the five
but i i believe oh here's something i
feel like you're in jail
i do you eat like you're in jail when
she does like when she when she works on
something she locks herself in an empty
room to work on it
and sits in the most uncomfortable chair
she owns so that she has to awake
like this yeah i do i do if i'm working
on a script
if i'm wearing a script or like new
stand-up or something like that i have
like an attic
and i will just do it's just a desk and
a chair and
if you're into cozy a workspace you're
going to want to stay there
and this is like i need to write 30
pages of this script
i'm going to put myself in an
uncomfortable situation as possible so
that i'm motivated to do it faster
prison like yeah situation yeah it's
like a masochistic
work ethic like you get people in their
office that's decorated there's flowers
and there's cushions and there's a yoga
ball i'm like why are you settling in
if you had like a bean bag you'd
probably fall asleep yeah this is not
good this is it i need to be as
uncomfortable as
possible that's sort of my goal um
that's your tinder bio
oh yeah okay this is how we're gonna end
the show what is your what after talking
to her for
how long have you been here four and a
half hours uh what is your bio
for your dating app god there were so
many good options
men have killed themselves for me
men set themselves on fire for me what
do you got i'm going with that i own two
houses
i own two houses star of your childhood
oh man we have to come up with it
i'm gonna go with i don't know his men
have killed themselves for me a little
much
that got a little bit money i'm going to
attract the wrong people
my life has been a nightmare that's good
that like starts off right off the bat
with like a little pity like
nightmare but you could be my dream yeah
there you go save my life
and ugg saved my life and then like
every picture will just be me and uggs
like different places um that's not
gonna get my brand
it's not gonna get me far i feel like i
have everything but a husband
i want your i like i like i have
everything but a husband i also think
boundary would be good like
boundaries would be good for you no
video games
if your mom cleans your house swipe left
my dad thinks i'm cooler than beyonce
that's a good one
yes yes tom cosgrove thinks i'm cool
you know what you should just put tom's
business address
like he's like just his just promote his
business
you should let your dad write your bio
that's the key
that would be that would be very
frightening no say uh
questions funny you should ask your
dad's favorite show
funny you should ask love tom cosgrove i
would say just put the link to this
podcast episode
okay if you want if you want to date me
listen to this first and then decide
and if you like it now you know
everything you need to know
that's true that'd be a good place to
start orchids you know how do you handle
a bad situation because they come at you
that's it i'm telling you can you put
out
fires are you good at
uh shifting through surveillance
yeah do you know first aid
well thank you guys for all of the
options
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna
carry those around
i'm gonna get those around and circle
back i'll let you know how it goes
and when we're done i'm gonna ask you a
dating app you're on okay
can i tell you you're a dream you're a
dream come true
truly guys you've truly on legend star i
mean i think we tried to do this in like
january and then the
covet happened everyone almost died yeah
we came back
and then i'm like i just you're just
like a breath of fresh air this makes me
think people don't have to be toxic
it's made me really tell me it makes me
like how many people in my life are so
toxic
this is also creepy but i'm on raya and
i actually like
put that i like girls so that i can see
the competition
and i saw your page so i already know
what you're on
i'm not doing anything you have a big
age bracket
oh what do you mean wait did i see you
on raya where's my phone
i did that too really i put it on girls
to see my competition
and it made me so depressed i didn't go
on it for like my one friend did it
first before i did and she started
talking to some girl and she thought
like the girl was really cool
and she wanted to like be friends with
the girl yeah the girl thought that she
like
wanted to go out with her so she had she
was like really upset about it for like
a while because she wanted to be friends
with a girl and the girl wanted to
she really liked talking to the girl
first she was just jealous of the girl
she thought the girl was like so
beautiful
and she couldn't believe it and then the
girl messaged her she was like oh hey
what's up
answered back and they started talking
got along really well and it turned into
like this whole weird thing
well your friend's gay also okay
thanks for petting me now just she
doesn't know that yet but
she's like i really like this girl and
she won't talk to me anymore and i
really love her but i don't want to date
her like she's
i mean in 2020 we're just outing people
yeah
i mean really i need to update my bio
my that is your bio i don't i don't i
mean oh i don't think
wait where's my phone sticker wait it's
right here
it's my photo right here oh uh my photos
are what why are you laughing
my this is my i actually have a fucking
bomb
okay what's your song oh my god this is
a dating app where you have to pick
at least three photos and a song if it's
not your own song i would
leave this that is such a powerful i
change it constantly it was it's whitney
houston
um simply the best or just oh good one
yeah okay so my bio i'll show it to you
i don't give a fuck i'll show you my
profile right now
hold on i need to add a bio everyone has
one mine is how do you go to your bio
hold on this is my dating app you guys
wait how do i go to my profile okay
oh god this photo i look like i look
like skeletor oh my god
your bio your page is so nice you don't
look like you're desperately trying to
like
okay this isn't desperate i feel like
people on their own
beautiful picture huh this is me by the
way
three years ago oh can you imagine uh in
full hair and makeup
full hair and makeup full princess leia
braids to try to get the silicon valley
nerds
to try to try to trigger the tech guys
to fall in love with me
and then you press it my second picture
me with the dog foot on my face
the next one you're kidding me what's
your song my song oh
the food's here uh me and that's a
fucking pathetic that's embarrassing
that's desperate
this is the funniest one though the last
picture
is neil brennan holding my raya profile
on his phone um the food i think is here
oh um okay so hold on
so if you so that's mine and my song is
a blood orange song
it's blood orange you're not good enough
it's a song called you're not good
enough so what happens when you look at
my bio
is it basically just says you're not
good enough that's a power move
yeah yeah yeah i'm all about uh power
move or just
being repellent hold on how come my
songs are playing
hold on silent mode ryan's like no
yeah wait why isn't play oh here we go
here it is
[Music]
you want to date me you into this huh
you want to sleep with three dogs in a
bed and a girl who only is on the bottom
swipe right yeah this song is very chill
for you
i know that's blood orange is like my
favorite band
okay let's see it oh my god this is my
nightmare that i'm getting with this
it's so embarrassing yes but look i got
my cat in
okay i mean it's not me smiling creepily
it's not cute it's the main one
i mean that's like a little up close
like why have you i couldn't make it
match with john cusack yet have you
have you have not matched with john no i
mean there are some very random
celebrities on here
um i when i i have to change
my what's it called uh edit
my preferences are people ever mean to
you if you don't answer like really
quickly
jesus like sometimes people are mean on
the app like
give me your fucking phone i will
respond to these people myself
i think people do not uh aren't
don't think to be mean to me this one's
good he said
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
you expire in eight days
would you answer that
it sounds kind of scary like the person
i mean i literally do my biological
clock actually expires in eight
um i so he wanted you to reach out to
him
well that's all he's ever said to me get
the fuck
out of here you should look at him
you're really surprised
guys with these guys who
want to be like roasty and negative and
like
sassy get the fuck out of here how about
it's a fucking honor to match with you
you queen how did i get so lucky
fuck out of here this one guy said hi
and then like three hours passed and
then he said well i guess i'll just go
fuck myself then
that one was like really crazy aggro i
was like jeez
that is people are like i'm gonna get
you on my wi-fi so that i could actually
start responding to these people
uh oh i just saw someone i know on
mariah
god damn it um a lot of these i'm trying
to think
i'm trying to see if i see any
celebrities oh i know him it's a lot of
comedians on here
a lot of dj's a lot of famous dj's that
rhyme
with bad bouts um
every people should like always have you
guys around when they sign up for dating
ads they'd have like a lot more
confidence on the app
mine just says comedian i that's what i
put is my job
i don't think but i don't think that
this has a
tagline i don't think you can put a
tagline on this app but sometimes people
have like a whole paragraph about
themselves i swear
well that's a narcissist that's a red
flag i also get a lot of like couples
like on here isn't that so weird has
that ever happened to you
that dm that you match with like people
are like married looking for a third
yeah don't don't walk into that hornet's
nest get don't step into those yellow
jackets
yeah you do not want to get involved in
someone's divorce
i just didn't even know that was a thing
so like if someone has someone with them
in their picture i think like i just
thought it was like their friend
and then all of a sudden like an open
relationship i guess
but like i just didn't even think anyone
really did that and then like people
will come up and they'll
like i don't have time to date one
person much less too i mean like what a
nightmare
honestly just call it call it okay dude
if you're sitting down having a big
conversation about an open relationship
just
call it put your put each other out of
each other's misery
and just fucking end it dude don't drag
other people
don't drag other people into your
fucking nightmare i mean can you imagine
sorry i'm really cracking myself up on
this i mean who
who who what are the chances that you're
gonna find someone that's gonna like
both of you
do you know what i mean why are they
caught looking for a unicorn right yeah
looking for you've never
heard that i barely like you somebody
yeah because yeah to find like a third
that's like into both people it's like
oh mystery yeah what are the chances i i
let me
figure out if i like you and then i can
decide if i like your girlfriend that
you don't like anymore
like if you don't want to keep fucking
each other why do i want to fuck both of
you like what are the chances
just because you guys are over each
other why would i fix this yeah
you were a baby oh god i would talk to
you all day
i guess we're gonna have to be friends
you're stuck with me um
what a delight uh follow miranda uh you
probably already do
um and uh you're gonna about to see some
hot content on her page because i have a
feeling benjamin's gonna take over all
of her
social media content don't ride
elephants uh per usual is there anything
you would like to say
um nope i think i got it all in there
thank you guys so much i told the round
two
love you guys
[Applause]